>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Moderator: Our first
presenter, Dr. Krista Lewis,
is an associate professor
of anthropology and chair
of the Department of
Sociology and Anthropology
at the University of
Arkansas at Little Rock.
She specializes in
archeology of Southern Arabia
and its relationships to
the wider Middle Eastern
and Indian Ocean regions.
Dr. Lewis leads two major
archeological projects
in South Arabia, one in
Yemen and one in Oman.
In Oman, she directs excavations
at the UNESCO World
Heritage Land
of Frankincense site
of Al-Baleed.
Her research engages issue
of urbanism, food waste,
resource extraction,
craft production, trade,
emerging globalization,
multicultural interactions
and sustainability
from prehistory
to the early modern period.
Dr. Lewis holds a PHD from
the Department of Anthropology
at the University of Chicago.
Please welcome Dr. Lewis.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Krista Lewis:
Al-Baleed was a mercantile,
administrative, and
cultural center,
and international port
city with a local heart.
This large walled city offers
a window into the emergence
of the globalized world
that we live in today.
Al-Baleed is a large
and visually stunning
archeological site stretching
for over a mile along
the Arabian Sea beach.
Its history stretches from
the Late Antique period
to the Early Modern, and its
transformations throughout
that time have much to teach us
about international
commercial transactions
and the cultural
interconnections
that generate and sustain them.
And, we heard earlier about --
sorry, is this -- I
hear myself loudly.
We heard early from
our speakers earlier,
especially Dr. Genouer
[assumed spelling] about some
of the very early origins of
globalization in this region.
So, trade and interconnection
have a very long history
in this area, but Al-Baleed
is a special place to look
at the connections between these
very ancient origins of trade
and interconnection globally all
the way up to the modern world
that we live in today.
So, there are many industries
and products associated
with the region during
the height of Al-Baleed,
including aloes, metals, beads,
textiles, ceramics, fish,
and the plant dyes
indigo and madder.
Most famously of course,
Al-Baleed is well-known
for having exported the regional
specialties of frankincense
and also Arabian horses.
Even more importantly, a wide
array of people and ideas
from throughout the
Indian Ocean region passed
through the gates of the city.
Just to give you a better idea
of where we're talking about,
I mean, you all know
where Oman is, of course.
But, note the southern Oman, the
Dhofar region, which is really
in the center of the Western
Indian Ocean trade circuits.
Moving, and I don't have a
pointer to show you this,
but maybe I could show you.
The reason I show
you this map is just
to highlight briefly the type
of geography we're looking
at in southern Oman,
and why it's special.
Each summer the Indian
Ocean monsoon brings rain
that turns this ring of
mountains, if you can kind
of see with the pointer,
green, a lush green,
and provides the moisture
that allows frankincense trees
to grow in this region.
So, frankincense is our only --
they're exploiting a very small
area along the back slopes
of the mountain.
And, you need just a certain
amount of moisture that comes
from this Indian Ocean Monsoon.
Notice also down here in this
other box where Salalah is,
this other area of green.
In this view to the north, you
can see part of the western end
of the walled city of
Al-Baleed and a closer view
of that second area of
green I pointed out.
It's a lush tropical
agricultural belt made possible
by the runoff and ground water
from those framing mountains
and the Indian Ocean monsoon.
Unlike much of Arabia which
is famous for its deserts,
Dhofar's unique environment
makes it an ideal place
to be able to found
and feed a city.
The agricultural products
from Salalah today are most
famously bananas and coconuts
and other forms of
tropical fruits.
But, what's even more
interesting, in the understory
of that orchard zone,
all sorts of plants
and animals are being raised,
so it's a really
highly productive belt.
So, a very special,
special place.
In this photo you
also see the locations
of the most common structures
on the site of Al-Baleed.
This is the impress --
there's the garden zone --
the citadel of Al-Baleed
and associated large
congregational mosque,
which you'll see
both of those later.
Am I just seeing some
of the other unexcavated
building mounds
in that [inaudible] site?
I'll just go ahead
while he gets those up.
The work of a number
of archeologists
at Al-Baleed has established the
basic sequence of occupation,
which can be bracketed
into subperiods
which you'd be seeing now
when the slides come up.
Based on the visual
architectural types,
radiocarbon dates, stratigraphy
-- okay, we're getting closer --
ceramic typology, coinage,
and historic narratives.
There you go.
There's our phases of the city.
So, from modest pre-Islamic
origins, the town grew
into a thriving city,
experiences a series
of political and economic
developments and phases
of reorganization,
reconstruction, and expansion
for well over a thousand years.
So, although we have structural
remnants and artifacts
from Late Antiquity,
what you see
in the upper righthand corner
that have been excavated
at Al-Baleed, due to the
intensive history of building
and rebuilding at this site,
exposure to these earlier
materials are necessarily
rather limited.
In this example in the
upper righthand corner,
you see some Late Antique
bezels and also some house walls
which are buried
meters below a mosque,
which is also below
another mosque.
So, you can't just
kind of remove all
of these later periods
to get down to the early.
The photo at the bottom
is the ground level view
of the mosque you saw
in the last slide.
It was founded by or before
about the mid-tenth century AD,
and saw a series of remodelings
over the history of the town,
as most buildings did.
This mosque had a flat
roof, a central courtyard,
a quart minaret, and an attached
ablution facility in the back.
Across the city, more than
50 other mosques have been
identified, many
small and square,
most of which probably date
between 1250 and 1400 AD.
This citadel which you also
saw in that overview shot,
is the most prominent
monument on site.
Also has seen a series of
rebuilds, enlargements,
and increased fortifications
from the tenth
to the 16th centuries.
It rose to at least four stories
and had an interior courtyard.
Iben Betutu wrote in 1340
AD that it was the residence
of a sultan, highlighting
Al-Baleed's importance
as an administrative
center for the region.
The south-facing view,
also the citadel,
highlights the lagoon
surrounding the site
and its importance for
defense as well as a source
of fresh water for the site.
So, those runoff coming from
the mountains, across a lot
of the Salalah Plain, you
don't actually see the water.
I mean, there are
springs, but in a lot
of areas you don't see the
water, but right when you get
to the sea where
these drainages occur,
you get these freshwater lagoons
which have been important
in settlement in Oman, you
know, since deepest Antiquity,
but certainly right up the
period of use of this site.
This is an artist's
reconstruction
of almost the same
view and the lagoons
around the site could
also provide a route
of transport by boat.
Al-Baleed's most impressive
defenses face the sea.
The south city wall
includes a series
of red [inaudible] base massive
towers, which you can see here,
and also in all these views.
But, up close and
an aerial view.
The city also has a number of
monumental city gates as well
as other less grand entrances
placed around the city wall.
There's also evidence for
locations where boats moored
for offloading and taking
on goods and supplies.
For example, the small
gate, which seems like it's
up in the air from the
city wall shown here,
probably had a wooden
pier that you would step
to reach the gate from.
The impressive archeological --
architectural features
certainly speak
to significant local
political and economic power,
but a really wide array
of imported good excavated
from Al-Baleed also
provide evidence
for its far-flung
global connections.
Ceramics, coinage, and a
variety of other artifacts
from Al-Baleed include
material of the origins of Yemen
and East Africa, from Egypt,
northern Middle East and Persia,
from India, wider South Asia,
Southeast Asia and China.
Glass and wood have also
been found at the site
from multiple origins
across the Indian Ocean.
In six seasons of work since
2013, my team has been working
to add a new dimension to
our knowledge of the site.
Our research at Al-Baleed seeks
to understand the daily
activities of the people
who lived and did business
there, examining the patterns
of urban life as they developed
uniquely in Southern Arabia
in the context
of its far-reaching
global trade connections.
Our work focuses on two
different sets of methods
over a range of scales.
One is very tactile,
traditional excavation,
looking at the spaces where
people lived and worked,
what they did, and who they
were through the minute
of their material cultural.
The other dimension is high
tech involving detailed mapping
on the ground and from
the air, as you see here,
and then using the
digital data gathered
to create three-dimensional
models.
This image is of a model
of the entire site created
from a composite of
air photographs taken
with an unmanned aerial vehicle.
It can be zoomed to a level
where individual
stones are visible.
It's not easy to demonstrate
that in a static slide show,
but here's an example of one of
the images and that's actually
at reduced quality there.
This is a funerary mosque
in the middle of the site.
You can zoom it in and
see individual stones.
You can clearly see the
individual surviving graves,
so this is going to allow us to
make a very high quality map.
This is false color
elevation model
and so it makes it a
little gaudy, but this kind
of visualization allows us
to see beyond what
can be discerned just
from a photograph.
We use image analysis to discern
buildings, neighborhoods,
courtyards, streets, and
maybe even industrial areas
in a way that's identifiable
more than they are
when you're actually on
site, on foot on the ground.
So, this is allowing us to
make a better, more, I guess,
analytical map of site and then
also identify areas targeted
for future excavation.
It also allows us to know
things about the site
without excavation which
is an important aspect
of site preservation.
How the city was organized
is an important aspect
of understand the life
ways of its inhabitants.
Note for example how, I'm
not going to go too much
into what you see here,
but the western end
of the site is much
higher mounded
than what you see at the east.
I'm going to, instead of talking
about our theories for the east
and then move on for right
now and show you this image,
which is facing northeast
to orient you, to bring you
in closer to that high mounded
western end of the site.
You've seen it at a slightly
different angle from before.
And, this also brings us
to the other [inaudible]
of our current research project.
So, the area we were excavating,
this is before we
started excavating,
it's in this really strategic
central part of the city
between the citadel,
which you see up here,
and a major city gate of
the site on the seaside.
So, this is just another view
looking the other direction
or from one of the major
customs areas of the site,
to where the major mound is
that we started working on,
and it's close to the sea.
So, what's interesting about
this is you can hopefully see
that in this area very high,
multistory collapsed
stone mounding here
and an open major
street or a courtyard.
And, this mound that we're
looking at faces directly
down this street or
courtyard towards the citadel.
Up close, this is a mound prior
to excavation and I just wanted
to give you a bit of a glimpse
of kind of what it looks
like as things start to
emerge underneath that.
It's pretty dramatic.
There's a lot of working
through this rubble, but rooms
and walls start to emerge.
Our investigations are
specifically designed
to recover artifacts, spaces,
and organic remains that look
at daily life for the residents
and the visitors to this port.
Here's a map of what
we have got here,
so for scale these are
five-meter squares,
so we're looking at
quite a large area.
Our work has revealed two areas
of two major building complexes.
You can maybe see the different
orientation of the walls
in this area and this section.
I know this pointer
is not ideal,
but these walls are running much
more north, south, east, west,
and these are at a bit of angle.
And, there's a lot of rebuilds,
as I've, it's kind of a theme
when talking about this site,
so it's not one coherent plan
but we're looking at phases
and phases of rebuilding
and remodeling over time.
For example, we can
see things that used
to be standard rooms get
subdivided or walled off,
people no longer want to use
certain areas and they want
to build on in others.
These two buildings do have
deposits that overlap in time,
so at least in the latest phases
of their occupation they
may have been related
as an extended family compound.
This is an example, just to
give you a glimpse of one
of the rooms, all right?
Note these two doors.
Here's a door that
hasn't been excavated.
We have since -- since
we've taken this photo,
this room has been
excavated as well.
this is the same room, just
a little more cleaned up,
but you can see two entrance
doors there, a hallway here.
So, all of these are excavations
in progress so you can sort
of see deposits we're
coming through.
Okay, and this picture's
going to illustrate that --
our evidence that this was a
multistory building, right?
So, here you have
a major staircase.
It's leading up to a
mostly destroyed upper floor
of the building.
We do have portions
of that upper floor,
so in this photo you see
a plaster floor upstairs
being uncovered.
That plaster floor is two
and a half meters higher
than the plaster
floor that we found
at the base of those stairs.
So, we also have flooring in
the room that I just showed you
at -- almost identical
within centimeters
of the same elevation
as the floor
at the bottom of the stairs.
So, we're able to identify
certain living levels
and certain floors
of the building.
Also, to kind of illustrate the
architecture of the building,
this partially excavated
room, if you notice here,
maybe you can just see a sort
of strange marking that seems
like it's in the plaster of the
remnants, plaster of this wall.
This is a door.
So, we're just beginning
to get in here.
You just see the top of the
door emerge, and this is one
of those doors that was
intentionally filled later on.
I guess they, you know, didn't
want to use this room anymore,
it was getting dangerous or dank
in the center of the building.
I don't know.
you can also see where this
wall is broken and that to kind
of illustrate is where the
ceiling would have been
for that room.
We know things about how
the ceilings were made
and where they were because
sometimes we find remnants
of them and that's what you
see in the other photo here.
This person is brushing
out basically the plaster
that was left when the beam
that was there rotted away
from this part of the ceiling.
So, that's when ceilings tend to
collapse is after the beams rot,
but sometimes we get these
sort of negative casts.
So, here's another
excavation reveal for you.
Prior to excavation,
the most north face
of the structure was
almost four meters high
on very steep mounding.
So, and, almost the same
direction you can see
after a season of excavation,
we removed a lot of that.
Now, it's here, waiting to
be taken away, and you start
to see a really --
building walls
and different phases
of occupation.
To flip it around, on
the same slope looking
at it directly facing south.
I'm not going to go too
much into that especially
because I don't have a pointer
to really show you anything,
but you have some very early
walls built of a sort of larger,
more -- a better
cut monumental stone
that we get in later phases.
You can see where she's
excavating and here
in the middle, some
intentional fill layers
in between this level and
the levels that are above.
We also have -- this is a
very interesting curved wall,
almost tower-like.
We're still working on
trying to interpret that.
So, archeological knowledge must
be constructed and strengthened
by multiple related lines
of evidence from production,
distribution, and
consumption contexts,
analyzed across all these
different scales from landscapes
of regions to the city plans,
the architecture, right?
So, things down to small as
microscopic, organic residues,
or charred grains in a hearth.
Archeologists most often are
reconstructing patterns of life
from artifacts such
as you see here.
I mean, small fragments
of pots, glass, coins.
In the next few slides,
I'm going to show you just a
few highlights quickly of some
of the things that we've
found in this building,
in these two building, and
what these artifacts kind
of give you a glimpse
of daily life.
Sharing food, drink, and
other consumable items
as we all just did,
it's an essential way
that humans everywhere show
their cultural identity,
display their status, mark
social events, enact generosity,
and facilitate financial
transactions.
The greatest proportion
of the artifacts found
in our excavations are
ceramics, bones, and other items
that tell us about
eating practices.
A significant portion
of those artifacts
and organic remains are related
to practices of hospitality,
generosity, and sociality.
So, the folks at this port may
have been sharing their cultural
way of life and their eating
with other people and I think
that we're getting
towards the level
of analysis is still ongoing
where we can start to pick
out that there are African
types of pottery and food items,
there are Indian types of
pottery and food items.
There are certainly local,
and so we're really interested
in this sort of multiethnic
identity of the port,
and was it place where people --
where we can really see people
getting along and, you know,
making relationships,
and generating these kind
of economic transactions.
Some other social activities we
see evidence of include games,
game boards, they chewed beetle
nuts in the very latest phases
of the city, tobacco
pipes start to emerge,
so they're smoking tobacco.
We also have instruments,
so music is something that,
you know, we would know should
be a part of a life in a city
and people going, enjoying
time together and food.
But, we have some actual
evidence and clearly a sort
of a wind instrument, the
bone recorder or flute,
some pieces of inlay you see.
These are inlay possible
from a stringed instrument.
I can't prove it, but
there's some interesting wear
along this.
If someone is an expert in
ancient instruments wants
to have a look, that'd be great.
We also have a pick
that might be a pick
for a lute-like instrument
for picking the strings.
They were all found close
by one another, too,
so that's interesting.
Maybe sort of a musical
section of the building.
Oil lamps, another interesting
piece of material culture
that sheds light on an everyday
reality of life in the city.
Most of the oil lamps are small
like these made of simple,
locally made terracotta
ceramics.
However, we also found this much
more elaborate star-shaped lamp.
This is quite lovely,
made of a soft soapstone,
which is not found
locally in Dhofar.
Evidence for this and also the
other lamps that, you know,
tell us that it was
actually used
for an oil lamp are the
burn points which I've kind
of highlighted on
this upper photo.
Each point had a wick
and a point of light.
The lamp was made to be
suspended by an iron pin
or a chain through
a central column.
So, with its multiple points of
light it would have been rather
like a small chandelier,
quite lovely.
This is just a historic
lamp from Yemen.
It's not star shaped, but just
to give you kind of an idea
of how it might have been
hung, how it would work.
Well, we also have some
perishable artifacts,
fibers such as this rope.
This is a small fragment
of cloth which is still
under analysis, but my expert
thinks it might be silk,
beautifully painted
wooden bowl fragment.
Another class of artifacts
that gives us a really I
think intimate view of people
who lived at Al-Baleed
is that of jewelry
and personal adornment.
Here are some examples.
some of the many different
types of beans that we find,
sizes, colors, materials.
Glass bracelets, we find
a lot of glass bracelets.
We find a lot of
glass bracelets.
So, bangle, shell bangle
showed up earlier in a talk.
These are glass.
Perfume bottles, so your
perfume bottle neck here
and also some bottle
fragments in this shot,
all of these items
are identified studied
and then we want to put them
back into the larger context
of where they're
found for analysis.
So, I'm just going
to bring you back
to the excavation
map again briefly
to kind of talk about that.
So, we want to look and we're
still working on this analysis,
but the statistical analysis of
the patterns and how they relate
to the architecture
are helping us
to understand not just
what happened at the city
or even just this structure,
but down to the level
of individual rooms and spaces.
We mentioned that the
musical instruments are coming
from the same which was
actually over here, the --
I just had a student who's
just finished measuring a lot
of glass bracelets and she's
found that some of them are
so small, the diameter, that
they must have been worn
by children, which
is quite interesting.
So, we're looking not at just an
administrative building where,
you know, men of the town
came, but a family space,
that we have, you know, the
women and we have children.
And, another thing that's quite
interesting is almost all,
I think except for one example
of those child size
bracelets all come
from two rooms right over here.
I don't know if we
have a nursery.
It's quite interesting.
I want to just turn briefly
to the building here,
the second building that we
started working in the east
and we've been working
west gradually
over six seasons of excavation.
And, so we're relatively
new getting
into the second building, which
used to be, it's a courtyard,
a large open courtyard
with small rooms around it.
And, I just wanted
to point out some
of these interesting
features that we have.
I just want to show
you up close.
So, this is another facet
of private lives here
in this courtyard,
we have basins or,
I think they're actually baths.
So, we have these lovely
plastered baths, they're small
by our standards, but they're
deep, kind of deep soaking tubs.
But, they are slightly
different in sizes.
Here's one, there's another,
there's excavators
working on it.
They have formal
plaster drain systems,
so they're very clean
[inaudible] and had a kind
of very intricate system of
water and drains, which we know
from elsewhere in the site, too,
but this I quite interesting
for this house complex.
For this excavation
project we've also developed
and deployed a unique
comprehensive mobile digital
data system.
And, this not only facilitates
rapid, comprehensive,
paperless data collection in
the field, but also relates,
integrates, and tracks all of
this excavation data from point
of origin to analysis
into long term storage.
We want this to be
efficient, but also to be able
to share data more immediately,
more fully, and more sustainably
in a way that fits a Global
Heritage site such as Al-Baleed,
and hopefully this will
have more and more spinoffs
for interaction of
visitors to Al-Baleed
with the data in the future.
Port cities are particularly
dynamic places,
both rooted in local patterns
and cultures, but also the site
for diverse multicultural
interactions.
They're places where not only
trade goods and diverse people,
but also a kaleidoscope
of ideas, cultures,
and ways of seeing the
world come into contact.
And, Al-Baleed's current role
as an archeological park this
is still as true as it ever was.
Visited by diverse people
from all over the world
in a new phase of its
occupation, the city is a place
where be both look to the
past and forge a new future.
Bringing together the two facets
of our project in excavation
and digital recording, new
horizons of interpretation,
scientific advancement, and
tourism become possible.
So, I just want to finish
with acknowledging the many,
many people that without
which this project would not be
possible, especially the folks
from the Office of the Advisor,
including Dr. Sunme [assumed
spelling], who's here,
and our team and everyone else
who's working on the project.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Moderator: Thank you,
Dr. Lewis for a wonderful
presentation.
Our next speaker is
Dr. Joy McCorriston.
Joy McCorriston is a professor
at the Ohio State University
Department of Anthropology
and director of the
ASOM Project,
Ancient Sociological
Systems in Oman.
She is an archeologist with 40
years of field work experience
in the Middle East that includes
Oman, Yemen, Jordan, and Egypt,
and has been conducting
research in Oman since 2009.
Her collaborative research has
discovered the earliest dates
for domesticated cattle
and sheep in Arabia,
older than 8000 Cal
BP, and established
that agricultural technologist
trailed pastoral adaptations
by some 2500 years.
In the fall, her team located
an excavated monument and tombs
of mutli-types as well
as two rural settlements.
Dr. McCorriston obtained her PHD
in rural anthropology
at Yale University.
Please welcome Dr. McCorriston.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Joy McCorriston:
Well, thank you very much.
It is a great honor and a
great pleasure to be here
in such a wonderful setting
and to see many familiar faces
and many new faces
with us today.
I want to start by thanking,
as our presenters
have done before me,
Dr. Deeb [assumed spelling]
and the Sultan Qaboos Cultural
Center and the Embassy of Oman
for hosting this and giving us
a chance to provide something
of a snapshot of some
ongoing projects that are some
of the more very
visible and some
of them are not so easy to see.
And, I think some of our
work is going to fall
in the latter category.
So, I'd like to talk about
monuments which are visible,
and mobility and
pastoral territoriality,
which is really behavior and as
it takes some archeological work
to tease that out and
make that visible.
So, those are topics that I
would like to lead in today.
What I'd like to do with you
in the next few minutes is
to explore what we can learn
about the dynamic lives
of ancient safaris.
And, if you walk away
from this presentation
with one simple idea, it is
that despite these
really magnificent ruins
that we've seen from other parts
of Oman and the spectacular site
of Al-Baleed on the coast
-- so here comes the idea,
a you with me -- 95
percent of all Omanis
who ever lived were
mobile people
and of those a very
large percentage
of them were pastoralists.
So, although I will not be
showing you spectacular objects,
I could like to make
the case this afternoon
that it is important to consider
the lives of these people
who have left a lot
less for us to look at.
I will talk a little bit about
pastoralism and archeology
and some of these challenges,
bringing that course
to the case of Dhofar.
And, in the spirit of the
broader presentation today,
although I am no expert on
cultural tourism, I recognized
that this is an important
component of Oman's heritage
and therefore I would like
to offer a few very amateur
thoughts about that.
So, I hope you'll indulge me.
Pastoralism in Dhofar,
we now know,
that it began about
8000 years ago.
That's a long time.
And, through that time,
pastoralism has been
a dynamic system.
It has also been a
long term adaptation,
a way in which people have
matched their social behaviors
to the availability of
resources, the distribution
of resources, really
developed a dynamic ecology.
And, in that process
over 8000 years,
pastoralists have changed
their environment even
as they have fitted themselves
to this dynamic changing
environment.
So, we talk about this really
as a niche, a pastoral niche,
the ancient safaris shaped the
world and the world shaped them
so that they really
hung onto to pastoralism
for a very long time.
But, what we understand
about pastoralism tends
to be very much framed
from what we can see
of pastoralist behaviors today.
Of the cultural anthropology and
I've met a couple of you who are
or have studied cultural
anthropology,
and it gives us a really great
understanding of behavior,
but it gives us a very static,
sort of snapshot "I was there,
I saw this for a year and
wrote it up" kind of impression
of what in Dhofar is really
a very long term history.
So, in Dhofar, a really
very wonderful portrait
of traditional pastoral
lifestyles was presented
by a German man named Jorg
Johnson [assumed spelling],
who was in Dhofar
in the middle 1970s
and wrote a seminal work
called "Nomads in the Sultanate
of Oman", which came
out in 1986.
We relied on that a
great deal in trying
to understand what
traditional life was like.
And, so this image before
you, it shows arrows that map
onto Dhofar and here I have to
thank Dr. Lewis for giving us
such a nice introduction
so I don't need
to tell you about the monsoon.
But, this maps a kind of
1970s mobility pattern
onto that landscape.
And, so the small sort of radius
around a certain
point is documenting,
meant to document the mobility
of the traditional cattle
herders in the mountains
who extensively relied
on a grassland plateau
which is very narrow actually.
It's only in some places
a few hundred meters wide.
And, these longer arrow map
a mobility and transhumance
of cattle herders back and
forth across the mountains
into the interior
and from the coast.
This is the ethnographic
present.
One thing we've been doing
as a team is trying to look
at the dynamics of
that environment,
which is also not static
and I don't think that comes
as a surprise to anyone
in this room to realize
that environments change.
Ours is changing today.
What has been learned
very recently by some
of the botanists from
the Oman Botanical Garden
and some earlier surveys is that
the grasslands on that plateau,
which provide this critical
resource for cattle eating --
excuse me, for grass
eating cattle,
those grasslands
are anthropogenic,
meaning that they were made by
burning off the cloud forest.
And, that anthropogenic
creation of grasslands is
in the botanical world a
fairly recent phenomenon.
We don't need to get
into how recent here,
but what it does tell us
is that there is change
and that the change is part of
that pastoral niche creation
that I was talking
about, niche construction.
So, the project that
I've been working
with most recently is
interested in trying
to understand what those
changes looked like over time
and how people engaged with
this changing landscape.
One thing that we know about
the changes in rainforest is
that those changes not
only happen on the plateau,
and so this image shows you,
I'm sure you've gathered by now,
you can see grasslands on the
plateau, and there's very,
very sharp and abrupt
transition to these steep slopes
where the cattle
don't graze as much
and you still have tree cover
from that Anglaises
[phonetic] Forest.
When you remove the tress
from the grassland on the top,
it has a spatial effect.
Those monsoon clouds
that Dr. Lewis talked
about don't penetrate as
far, they're not drawn
into the interior
and so it means
that the vegetation way deep
into the Nedjid's changes
and we heard this morning from
Dr. Asalami [assumed spelling]
about the changes in the Nedjid
and how we recognize those are
important and deep prehistory.
But, those cycles may
have been changing
in smaller cyclical
events over time.
So, we are very interested
in pursuing that.
And, in pursuing the behavior
and adaptation of those many,
many people who were
pastoralists in ancient Oman.
Okay, a little bit about
pastoralists and archeology,
and I'm showing you a
picture of a village in Syria.
This is the only picture
that is not of Oman,
but I have a reason
for doing this.
This picture is a village
that's made of mudbrick.
When these houses fall
down after about 25 years,
the mudbrick crumbles into mud,
or dry dust if you're
in Mesopotamia.
And, it seals in and holds
down all kinds of garbage
that people leave behind,
broken pottery, pieces of bone,
bits of copper, all kinds
of things that can tell us
about the ways people lived.
Pastoralists don't
live like this.
They mostly don't
settle in built houses.
They move around with their
animals because the animals need
to move on once they've
grazed grass,
meaning that we don't have
the kind of site formation
for ancient pastoralists.
So, archeologists looking
for a site will drive around
and they'll see something
really big
and they'll say, "That's great."
And, they'll learn about
five percent of the people
that ever lived in Oman, which
is wonderful, but we have less
of a record of the
lives of other people
and therefore it's harder to
understand their behavior.
So, places like Sumhuram in
Dhofar on the coast, you know,
we've also heard about it
as Khor Rori, Al-Baleed,
the Oasis of the North with the
al Falaj, very highly visible.
But, very few of the populations
ever lived in there places.
The material of --
the material culture
of pastoralists is
typically light,
sparse, and often organic.
Now this is something
that we can be grateful
to cultural anthropologists
for, again,
because we can see
how pastoralists live
in the modern day.
And, being mobile people
they don't carry one
of those great big, heavy, Indus
water jars or whatever they had
in them that is going to be
really tough to lug around
and if you drop it it'll break.
Pastoralists tend to make things
out of leather, out of wood,
out of basketry, out of
leather-lined basketry
if you want to boil milk.
They tend to use things
like feathers and dyes
and thatch to make shelters.
So, my point is that
these things decay.
And, so there is without
good site preservation,
there's not a lot
for us to find.
So, why is she doing
this, you're wondering.
Here are the problems.
Pastoralists move around a lot
so the sites are very ephemeral,
they aren't these big, deep
installations with a lot
of labor to build really
solid, lasting walls.
They don't practice agriculture,
at least they did not in Dhofar,
and that makes them very special
in the world of pastoralists.
But, they don't leave a
lot of plant remains for us
to understand what they
eat in the plant world.
They don't want to kill
off all their animals.
This is not, you know,
the butcher's shop.
These animals are precious and
so they are conserving them
and using them for milk and
only killing them occasionally
on special occasions.
So, we don't see a
lot of animal bone
from these very ephemeral sites.
They're very mobile, so they're
not carrying a lot around
and what is is light,
flexible, tends to be organic.
They tend to have a
tribal social identity
for long periods of time.
So, it means that who
they see themselves
as being is not really
determined
by how much gold they have
or how big a house they have
or how much wealth
they've accumulated
in terms of solid things.
They tend to have other ways of
identifying their relationships
to each other as social groups.
And, they have very low
population densities compared
to, say, a place like Al-Baleed.
This makes it difficult
as archeologists
to figure out what to do.
It's really very hard with this
lack of information even to look
at the sites that are available
and to understand the
reuse of the sites.
So, it's hard, but what I want
to do now is talk about the case
of Dhofar and talk
about what we can learn
about these very important
people who were the backbone
of Oman's long term
heritage one might say.
These image -- I lied, actually
-- the image on the, let's see,
it would be your left, is not
from Oman, but it is an image
of a very widespread
Bronze Age tradition
of depicting pastoral peoples.
And, it comes from
fairly nearby.
It's an Arabian find and it
shows the very prominent dagger.
And, sometimes we do find these
markers of social identities
on the righthand side is
a blade from an Omani tomb
which actually was
excavated by two
of our speakers this
morning, Michael Harrower
and Kimberly Williams.
And, one of the things
that interesting
about this is it came
out of a Bronze Age tomb
and the edges are rolled.
This was not meant to be used.
This dagger had these
finely blunted edges.
So, it was probably worn, a very
prestigious object of identity,
but not really meant to be
drawn and used to kill anything.
Other ways pastoralists
were visible
in archeology include sites.
They leave hearths, some
of that has charcoal
that can provide dates.
They clear vegetation, they move
stones around, they drag them
to hold down tents,
they drag them to hold
down animals, to corral animals.
They put up little
platforms to stick bedding
on top of to keep it dry.
We see graffiti and
bedrock mortars, enclosures,
all kinds of things that
are left in the landscape.
The other thing that
they leave behind,
and this is particularly
important
in Dhofar is territory
markers, and we see some
on the hill here,
right along there.
And, I believe you've
seen some important tombs
on the hilltops earlier
in this session.
So, these are territory markers,
they often appear at places
or near places where there
are good sources of water.
They may mark routes
or hunting blinds.
They may mark other
well sources.
And, my teams have been
examining these for a number
of years looking at them
both in their spatial
and chronological dimensions.
Here you can see a
platform or cairn.
This is not one that we
excavated, but it conforms
to a type of Bronze Age
cairn that we see there.
This is a typical monument
of about 2000 years ago,
a very different
style of monument
but nevertheless a very small
scale investment of labor
in building these
stone monuments.
And, here's a boulder that
has been elaborately marked
on the surface with foot
petroglyphs of footprints,
maybe snakes or winding water,
some texts in a Dhofari script.
So, important points, shaped and
marked by pastoralists moving
through this landscape.
We've also been exploring the
chronology of these monuments,
looking at burials in tombs and
also looking at the kinds of,
not along the styles
of the monuments,
but the different periods
in which they are excavated.
So, here they can see, again,
Dr. Kimberly Williams
excavating a tomb in Dhofar.
The result of this work over
a number of years has been
to recognize the spatial
distribution of a number
of small monuments,
but also differences
in style and in chronology.
And, so we have been
able to look
into all these different
types and I won't go
into what they are, but
I'd also like to point
out that we have developed a
dataset that provides something
of a pattern that's pointing
to some kind of dynamism.
So, I talked about
pastoralism being dynamic.
We can see these markers are
changing in style through time.
We also can see that there
seem to be some pulses
of when things are being marked
and territory perhaps is being
expressed and when there seems
to be a more open system.
So, this pattern is the result
of a number of years of work.
And, just a few images of
some of these structures.
This is a view of a
platform structure
from the Neolithic period.
We have not found burials
in this particular
style of platform.
That's a hypothesis
to be tested further.
I think we haven't excavated
as many as we might like to.
But, for the moment the evidence
that we do have seems to point
to some kind of commemorative
event, something happened big,
a big feast, a big
gathering of people.
we have some data from outside
of Dhofar that kind of point
to this sort of interpretation.
And, then a monument
was put in place to kind
of commemorate that
large gathering.
Other kinds of monuments
later in time include tombs
which still are markers.
And, these are placed
very high, very visible.
They seem to tie people
not so much to the memory
of a gathering and a social
community but to a lineage
and a genealogy, the memory
of who was in this tomb,
when that person was buried,
when that tomb was last visited.
So, we see more of a
chronological depth
to the memories around
these monuments and less
of a large-scale gathering.
So, we see some -- perhaps
some change in the behaviors
of pastoralists through time.
And, this may, in
fact, be the beginning
of these genealogical structures
that shape the social
identities as tribes.
One thing that the
project has been working
on recently is there
are some settlements.
So, I spent a few minutes
telling you how difficult it is
to reconstruct pastoral
lifestyles from settlement,
but we actually do have some.
And, it really surprised us that
these settlements were as robust
as they turned out to be.
So, we find circular,
little circular structures
with some well-built
construction,
kind of a bee hive
corrivalled vault to them,
four layers of floors.
So, people would live in them,
they'd toss down garbage,
they'd put down more
paving stones in the base,
they'd live in them again, and
we find three or four episodes.
Sometimes the ground surface
on these built up so much
that you would have to
walk down and stoop to get
into these earlier
ground surfaces
where these habitations
had been built.
And, here you can see in
the background of several
of the more recent team
members, a site that is in kind
of a basin or bowl
and has a number
of these stone structures,
but they don't look
like much on the surface.
In fact, if you didn't
know what you were looking
for you would think they
were maybe one stone deep
and there was not
much to do there.
So, again, they're not
visually deeply impressive,
but they do archive information
about an important
constituent of Oman's heritage.
Here's a map that we may --
I'm just showing you this
because I want to impress you
with how wonderful
my mapping team.
And, so I don't personally
take a lot of credit for this,
but you can see that they've
gotten a digital elevation model
out of some remote imagery.
In this case we just flew a kite
and then they've gone around
and mapped using an
instrument, the little corrals
and cell structures, the
little buildings attached
to those corrals.
And, you can see there's
a number of cairns
and platforms in
this area as well.
So, chronologically
and spatially this is quite
a complex little site,
which I just showed
you doesn't look
like a whole lot on the surface.
Some more images from that
site, just giving you a sense
of the -- what the interiors of
some of these structures here,
quarter has been excavated out.
Here we have a half with
a nice entrance way,
so you can see there's
some depth.
So, we're able to find
things in those structures
like the occasional grinding
stone, there's a lot of bone
in there, gives us a sense
of what people were eating
and what was important
to them and their herds.
So, going back to that gap,
I just wanted to remind you
that we have now
both settlements
and we have small scale
monuments that are telling us
about people's access
to resources,
the places that were important
to build in, to stay in,
to assert some kind of
visual presence even
when they were not
actually present
because they were
wondering with cattle
to temporary grasslands
or forage areas.
So, we're actually now
testing this map, this pattern
with a model in which
territoriality behavior plays a
role, in which we are
looking at the shift
from perhaps an open
property regime which would be
in these periods when we know
there are lower populations
elsewhere in the
Arabian Peninsula.
And, we would think
there would be an open --
more of an open availability
of resources
and high mobility going
back and forth to resources.
As populations grow in better
times, perhaps with the --
perhaps with concentration
around resources,
there would be lower mobility
and in between trees might take
over in abandoned
grassland areas and leading
to a population decline
in some of those areas
and a return of grasses.
So, the project going forward
is really testing this idea
of there being a dynamic system
that couples the human behavior,
the human social dynamic
and mobility with changes
in the environment
with the shift
between anthropogenic grasslands
and the recovery of
tress in between .
So, we're really interested
in that long term dynamism
and as I've tried to show
you the low term changes
where people come back to using
monuments over and over again
to express their
presence in a region,
but doing so in some
very different ways,
kind of shaping monuments
differently,
relating to them
differently as tombs
or as platforms and
gathering places.
So, I said I would end
with a few implications
for cultural tourism in Oman.
Bear with me, the picture
you see here is the picture
of the interpretation of these
very important people in Oman.
This is the site that tourists
are going to come to see,
and you can see, well, it
remains open for development.
Pastoralists were the majority
of people who lived in Dhofar.
They did leave materials.
They did leave material
remains all over the place.
And, yet, there is no really
good public interpretation
of ancient pastoralists
that's focused on a site
where people actually were.
You can go out and
look at these monuments
but they don't have
interpretive signs.
They don't have an
interpretive visitor center,
they don't have pathways
to lead people around them
and help people to understand
how they actually fit
into a landscape and
a dynamic landscape,
how people have shaped
the Dhofar
that we can visit and see today.
So, I would argue
from my very naive
and amateur research
position, as a non-specialist
in cultural tourism, that
there is work to be done
in cultural tourism and
that this is an important
and overlooked part
of Oman's heritage.
So, I want -- this
is my final slide.
I want to thank the
tremendous support we've had
over the years, and most
importantly I'd like to thank al
of the members of the teams who
have worked on various aspects
of this project who this would
not have happened without you.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Moderator: Thank
you, Dr. McCorriston,
for your presentation.
Our next speaker is
Dr. Michael Harrower.
Michael Harrower is an associate
professor of archeology
at John Hopkins University.
His research is focused on
Southern Arabia since 2000,
where he began his field work
in Dhofar in 2009 and 2010.
He continues work in Oman
today as the director
of Archeological Water
Histories of Oman or ARWHO.
He is a specialist in
satellite imagery mapping
and his research has been funded
by agencies including NASA,
the National Science Foundation,
the Archeological Institute
of America and National
Geographic.
Dr. Harrower obtained
his PHD in anthropology
from Ohio State University.
Please welcome Dr. Harrower.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Michael Harrower:
Okay, thank you.
Well, I'd like to start off
by saying thank you very much
to the Library of Congress
and to the Sultan Qaboos
Cultural Center for organizing.
It's a wonderful opportunity.
I'm so pleased to
be here and learn
about all the excellent
work that people are doing.
I just returned from Cairo
yesterday, so I'm totally
on the wrong time zone.
So, I've never dozed off
during one of my own talks,
and I thought it was probably
not a good time to start.
So, I thought I'd
use the lectern.
I would just start off
by saying, you know,
if we were to go out on
the street in Washington
and ask somebody
about ancient Egypt
and whether ancient
Egypt was important,
there would be no debate, right?
Everyone would say that there's
a wonderful archeological
history in Egypt and it's
of global significance.
But, there's less recognition
really of the tremendous work,
much of which has been
presented today, about Oman,
the new discoveries,
the grand history,
and the really critical role
in the ancient world
that Oman played.
So, I'm going to speed
through today to give you kind
of a little bit of a window into
work that I've been involved
with over the past 20
years in Yemen and in Oman
and including a kind of a
focus on my recent project
that concentrates along the
border with the Emirates up here
where you see Bat on
the map shown here.
So, my most recent book
I kind of took a look
at the long term role of water
in the history of ancient Yemen
and compared that to the role
of water in American history
and the settlement of the United
States and the American West.
And, despite these really
obvious differences that we see,
you know, in culture and
language and clothing
in so many aspects, I think
what's really striking is
that there are some broad
underpinning similarities
between parts of the
world that we think of us
as being so very different.
And, this is where Oman
really to my mind is one
of the most important
countries in the world today.
If you think about the
issues that we face in terms
of cultural understanding,
cultural interchange, war,
conflict, climate change,
the real answers to a lot
of those I would say, I really
try to argue this in my book,
involve building a mutual
sense of understanding
between people of
the world, right?
A common understanding of
language, culture, history,
by which we can build some
shared values and understanding
of how to proceed
in a cooperative way
to address these.
And, this I something that Oman
has played a tremendous role
in the world, and
really is a model
of cultural and public
diplomacy.
So, that is something I'd
really like to highlight.
So, let's speed through here
and I'm going to start off
with really giving you a
lightning-fast introduction
to some of the periods
we're dealing with here.
So, I spent a couple of years
working in Dhofar and I'm going
to return to Dhofar and kind
of give you some touch
stones to think about.
But, most recently I've been
directing a project called the
Archeological Water Histories
of Oman or the ARWHO project.
And, this has been funded
over the last three years
by NASA involving archeological
survey or basically exploration.
And, so as part of this
exploration we really touch
on all sorts of different
time periods, right?
It was mentioned earlier
this morning that really some
of the earliest history of human
ancestors in Oman goes back more
than a million years ago,
even two million years ago
in the Paleolithic period.
Then we arrive into
the Neolithic period
where the development of
pastoralism, agriculture,
shows up, and this
is a really critical,
interesting topic
for archeologists.
Why did the first people engage
in agriculture and pastoralism?
Then we get into this
Bronze Age period,
much of which you've seen.
Some of the hallmarks today have
Phi [phonetic] period tombs,
Umamnar [phonetic] period
settlements and towers,
and the Wadi Suq period.
The Iron Age I'm going to
touch on a little bit in terms
of the production of metal
and the international trade
that goes on in that period.
And, then of course,
the Islamic period
and the crucial role played
by the political economy
and circumstance at that time
which leads to the impressive
and rapid spread of
Islam through Arabia
and throughout the world.
So, about ten years ago
when I started working
in northern Oman, you know,
we charted out a massive
area to kind of look at.
And, today there's many, many
projects working in this area,
Polish teams, Dutch teams,
American teams, Japanese
researchers.
So, it's really exciting to see
really the knowledge of Oman
and the history of Oman
change very rapidly.
In addition to sort of
broad scale exploration,
driving around, leaving
no stone left unturned,
using satellite imagery,
talking to local peoples,
we also do a sort of
statistical survey
and on the righthand side here,
you can see these little colored
lines represent my teams walking
and surveying in a
systematic way on the ground
to document everything
we find in terms
of the archeological history.
One of the most interesting
sites we found, Abu Sue,
is north of the town Yanqul in
which we are often centered.
And, I was there just recently
with a French archeologist,
Dr. Remy Crusard
[assumed spelling],
who's one of the leading
experts in lithics
of the Arabian peninsula, and
I often get asked, you know,
like what's it like to discover
something transformative?
And, this is really an example
of that because I reached
down into the sand,
picked up this stone tool,
handed it to Remy and said,
you know, "What is it, Remy?
What is it?"
And, he immediately, I could
see the look on his face,
he got very excited because this
was a levawa [phonetic] point,
something he spent really
his career studying.
So, it doesn't look like
much to the untrained eye,
but we know these are about
75,000 to 100,000 years old
and really paint a picture
of some of the early people
that are establishing themselves
in the Arabian Peninsula.
Other stone tools that get
people really excited include
faade, projectile
points like this one.
If we think of the cusp of
how hunter-gatherers transform
into pastoralists these
are sort of centered
about 8000 years ago
during that period.
And, we really -- the people
that produced these are very,
very mysterious to us
because we don't have,
as Dr. McCorriston
mentioned, really rich evidence
from settlements that would tell
us about the lives of people
that produced these, but they
are found widely throughout
Yemen, throughout Oman,
Dhofar, and likewise.
Then we get into the Neolithic
period, so these are found
at a site called Wadi Olathli
[phonetic] near Yanqul, a very,
very large Neolithic site.
So, a couple of hectares,
a couple of football fields
in size and all sorts
of types of stone tools
that we can recognize
form the Neolithic period.
You heard about quite a lot
today the work in Dhofar
and in other parts
of Oman having to do
with Bronze Age tombs.
So, these are what we
might call in some parts
of Oman Hafeet tombs
or Hafeet-like tombs,
and these are excavations
shown here in Dhofar led
by Dr. McCorriston and
skeletal analysis done
by Dr. Kimberly Williams
of these types of tombs.
And, they're so very interesting
to us because we find tombs
of this genre throughout
the Arabian peninsula,
even up into the Sinai,
throughout Yemen and Oman
and they fall in the range
of about 5000 years ago
to a little bit younger
in large numbers.
This is another tomb from Dhofar
that we found particularly
intriguing because it falls
in this range of
roughly 5000 years ago.
We found a couple of these
tombs in, one of them,
the first one discovered
was found in Wadi Halluf
and that's how it get's
the name Halluf tomb.
And, one of the interesting
things we found
in this tomb is a dagger
that actually Professor
McCorriston showed you some
slides on, and really thoughtful
archeologists debate the,
you know, the chronology of
this tomb, the chronology
of this dagger, how did this
dagger wind up in this tomb?
Oman is really famous
for copper production
so at the very early end
we're looking at about 3200 BC
when Hafeet tombs
start to show up
and we find copper
production happening
and these are really exciting
for us to think about, you know?
Where did the copper
from for that dagger?
How did it find its
way into that tomb.
During the Umamnar period we
find some really impressive
towers developed and there's
been a lot of work on these.
There's more than 60 or
70 towers been documented
by Dr. Charlotte
Cable, Chris Thornton,
and others throughout
Oman's history.
This one is one we worked
on quite extensively
and what's intriguing, all
those this is 180 kilometers
from the coast, it's got a
pictograph on it of a boat.
And, we're really interested
to think about how the people
of this inland area were in
connection with the coastline,
were trading, were domesticating
animals and whatnot.
And, these tombs are closely
associated with water,
and this is sort of a
hallmark of tombs and towers.
This is a well in the
middle of this tower.
So, we did quite a bit of work
reconstructing the landscape
around Yanqul.
This is satellite imagery
and topographic data
and this orange areas here
are showing the vegetation
around Yanqul and
the Date Palm Oasis.
This is some of our
publications of that work;.
And, we did some
three D modeling.
This is something
that archeologists
have just really taken
up with a tremendous
passion in the past few years
because this technology has
become vastly less expensive.
And, so we did some three D
modeling of this tower to try
to understand its construction.
We did a whole bunch of
on the ground modeling.
So, one of the things we
realized is this town was
constructed by blocks that
are almost as big as one
of the tables up here
of the -- at the podium.
And, they're just enormously
heavy and it's so interesting
to think about how
these were moved,
but one of the things
that's an advantage
to us is these blocks
are so heavy, excuse me,
that most of them
that are fallen
over didn't get very far away.
So, all these little black
dots are blocks that we mapped
on the ground to try to
understand how this tomb
over the time, over the past
4500 years has deteriorated
and then I had some
colleagues, an architect,
and students reconstruct this
using the drawing of the tomb
in sort of a digital game
of Lego here putting all
of these little blocks,
measured blocks back to try
to reconstruct the
height of this tower,
which we estimate stands
about eight meters tall.
Nearby, returning to
the site of Abu Sue,
we found some other
interesting things
from this Umamnar
Bronze Age period.
We were there in 2012 and
documented some Umamnar tombs.
These are not something that
the untrained eye would get
excited about.
Really if you weren't carefully
looking walking right over top
of this without really
noticing it was significant.
And, one of the things
that really was touched
on throughout a number
of the talks today is the
challenges archeologists face
in Oman and really around
the world, sort of trying
to preserve and protect
cultural heritage, right?
And, so quite unfortunately
despite our efforts, these --
number of tombs in this
area were bulldozed, right?
And, so a big part of our work
is sort of public outreach or,
you know, education having to do
with the archeological history.
And, the, you know, development
in Oman is proceeding
at such a rapid pace, right,
that one of our challenges
is just reaching
out to local communities
and trying to work very hard
at sign boarding and protecting
some of this material.
And, these are some of
the objects that came
out of these tombs, right?
So, really some tremendous
material.
This is some soft stone
vessel pottery, shell,
and other materials, and
it's a running battle really
to preserve and save
some of this
that we're working very hard
on with the Omani Ministry
of Heritage and Culture.
One of the things Oman is really
famous for, of course, is copper
and bronze production.
So, the Bronze Age and later,
not surprisingly,
is known for bronze.
This shows you some raw copper,
but usually most of the copper
in Oman comes in the form
of copper in minerals
that are found throughout Oman.
And, while today mining
companies and modern production
of copper is in search
of big commercially
viable deposits, right?
They're not interested in
small quantities of copper,
but something we
can really develop
as a commercial enterprise.
Archeologists on the
other hand are interested
in the really smaller
quantities of copper
that people have been exploiting
and trading throughout
the Middle East
for at least 5000 years.
And, a large part of our work
with NASA satellite
imagery includes work
with hyperspectral imagery
from this satellite
here called Hyperion.
That is akin to having
240 different pictures
of different wavelengths
of light on the ground.
So, this can tell you a lot
about what you're looking
at in terms of the geology.
And, so while we've long
known for a very long period
of time the geological
formations in Oman
that yields copper, what is much
more challenging to do is to try
to pinpoint where the copper
bearing minerals showing
on this map, how
they're distributed
and how people were using them.
And, one of the things
we've really learned is
that it's not only the
presence of copper.
But, it's also the presence
of water to grow the food,
to supply the people doing
this copper production,
and also the presence of
trees to produce the charcoal
to smelt this copper, right?
So, as was mentioned earlier
today, the search of trees
to make the charcoal
is very, very important
from the Bronze Age and
especially into the Iron Age
where you have hundreds
of thousands of tons
in the Iron Age in
Islamic period
of copper slag being
produced in Oman.
One of the sites that
was discovered a handful
of years back that's really
critical in this regard
in revealing just some of
the astonishing things going
on in terms of copper
production is Saffah [phonetic]
or Ugdat Al-Baqarah and this is
about 30 kilometers
into the desert.
Was discovered on the edge
of the Rubahali [phonetic]
in the desert sand dunes and
there's hundreds and hundreds
of furnaces or pits
being identified first
by Italian research and the
Ministry of Heritage and Culture
in this area and hundreds and
hundreds of bronze objects
like this dagger shown here.
A lot of these are now -- a
potion of these are on display
in the new Oman National Museum.
And, one of the really
intriguing questions
about this material and these
images are from the archives
of the Oman Ministry of
Heritage and Culture,
is just the impressive quantity
of different material, daggers,
axes, bowls, and other material
that came out of this area
and been subject to
work by German, Italian,
and variety of different
international teams.
And, so I'm really
indebted to them
for their impressive
work on this material.
And, this is really akin, when
I think about explaining this
to my students, I oftentimes say
this is akin to being, you know,
camping out in the desert, and
let's say or argument's sake,
you were camping
out in the desert
and you had a thousand iPhones.
In a sense this was what
an iPhone is to us now.
It's something incredibly
valuable, right?
An d, if you have had,
for argument's sake,
a thousand iPhones, I don't
know how you'd have a thousand
iPhones, but say in a cardboard
box or a backpack or you knows.
You had a thousand iPhones.
You were camping
out in the desert
and somehow you were forced
to flee really quickly.
Maybe there's a sandstorm or
you were attacked and you had
to run away really fast, right?
What most likely you do is go
back and find that material
or whoever attacked you
would want to keep it
or you would go back the next
week or month or a period
of time later and
retrieve it, right?
For some strange reason, in
this case, that never happened
and this perhaps was
buried deeply in a sandstorm
that maybe transformed the
landscape so dramatically
that people were
unable to find the spot.
Or, for whatever reason this
material wasn't retrieved
from this desert area.
So, our work at the
site is really focused
in on satellite imagery.
We're using Japanese,
German, Canadian radar.
We're using GPR, ground
penetrating radar,
to try to understand where
people were living at this site,
where were they getting
water, why were they out here
in the middle of the desert.
The really impressive advantage
of satellite radar and radar
in general is it
has the capability
to penetrate beneath the ground.
So, especially in
really dry sand,
radar waves can penetrate
very, very deeply
and give you an image of
what's underneath the ground
without having to dig.
So, we had a team out in 2017
at Saffah, doing magnetometry
and ground penetrating
radar in the area
that was documented
previously by an Italian team.
And, we've documented many,
many of these furnaces or pits
that weren't visible
on the surface.
So, there's hundreds and
hundreds of them on the surface.
There's hundreds and
hundreds more of them --
underneath the surface of the
ground and these bowtie type
of reflections are what
you get when radar waves go
down into the ground
and bounce back up.
The other thing we noted
is that you think, well,
this is in the middle of
the desert sand dunes.
Where in the world could
they be getting their water?
One of the things
we recognized in GPR
and in satellite radar is there
is actually a drainage going
right through the
middle of this site.
Not now, but 3000 years ago
when this site was occupied,
there was water and
probably tress
and that may give us a clue
to why they're out here.
Maybe they're using these pits
to produce charcoal that is used
in the smelting or the melting
or the production
of this material.
And, we dug a number
of different trenches
in these red polygons
in early 2018.
These are examples of the
pits that we see in radar,
quite modest, small,
little pits.
These are four by
four excavations,
and we also did a trench across
the drainage that we identified,
the sort of natural small
stream running through the site
and this is flanked by pits.
And, what's really
interesting, too,
is this drawing shows a
cross-section of this channel is
that there's pits there that
are covered over by water flow
and by some of this
water laden sand.
So, we know that not only there
was water flow before people
arrived there but actually
there was water flow
in that desert area even after
or intermittently while
people were burning charcoal
or using furnaces or involved
in either massive scale food
production or metal production.
We're also collaborating with
Professor Kneuer [phonetic]
that he gave you a wonderful
presentation earlier today
on beads.
So, this is a bead we
retrieved from the surface.
We're very interested in the
trade connections not only
of where the bronze
material comes from
but whether we can situate the
location of the carnelian used
to produce this bead and
another one like it that's now
in the national museum.
Another really critical piece of
work we're working on in terms
of trade is a site we discovered
in 2015 called the Ker Al-Shamus
[phonetic] and this was
in close cooperation
with the ministry
of heritage and culture.
This is showing you
this small village
on a very tight bend in a wadi.
And, there's some of
the buildings here,
and what this site is
really amazing and important
for is being the first discovery
of soft stone chloride vessel
production known in Oman.
So, in fact known in Arabia.
So, prior to this time, we know
that really amazing material
made of out this soft stone,
you know, the layman's term in
English for this is soapstone
and it's almost got
a soft, soapy feel.
And, we know in in the
Bronze Ave and Iron Age,
Iran was a major center
point of production
of really glorious vessels,
many of them now in museums,
produced out of this
type of stone.
Archeologists have
known for decades
that the geological conditions
are right for the mining
of this type of material.
But, prior to the
discovery of Ker Al-Shamus,
we never found evidence
of people actually making
this stuff and trading it on.
So, while these pictures
look really rough and none
of this material is really going
to find your way on display,
you know, on a prominent
display in a museum,
these are really scientifically
so interesting to us
because they're roughed
out, early shapes of vessels
that were carved into
elaborately decorated examples.
So, we're starting to learn
about the geological knowledge
of these ancient people,
how they're mining this,
chiseling this, polishing
it down, working it,
smoothing it, shaping it.
And, we've got a paper, another
paper just in the final stages
of revision where we used
Hyperion hyperspectral satellite
imagery to go searching for the
source of the mine that was used
to collect this material
and we've got some really
interesting analysis showing
that a few, about
an hour's walk away,
up a very steep mountainous
wadi, people were mining
and collecting this material.
Coming back to Dhofar,
really one of the things
that Dhofar is really famous
for are these triliths
that were also touched
on earlier today.
We've learned a little
bit more about these,
but they really remain one
of the most mysterious
small-scale monuments in Arabia
and these are sort of
centered in Dhofar, right?
The densest, most abundant
examples of these are in Dhofar.
There's quite a number of them
in eastern Yemen in Hadhramaut,
there's some in Charkia
[phonetic], there are some --
there's a handful of
ones in northern Oman.
And, we know that likely
the people that are involved
in the early camel caravans
and trade routes and networks
that connect the Arabian
Peninsula are stopping at these
or involved in some kind of
use of these early monuments
and probably that may
include trade in frankincense.
And, many of you might not know
that there's a running rivalry
between Canada and Oman for the
most valuable form of tree sap.
So, Canada of course, the home
of maple syrup, has, you know,
a really lucrative
trade in maple syrup.
But, in ancient Oman, it's
number one in terms of the trade
of this impressive form
of tree sap, frankincense,
that led to the kingdoms and
the civilizations becoming
extraordinarily wealthy trading
this throughout the world
to Egypt, the Mediterranean,
to the Roman world
throughout this period of time.
So, I'll conclude just
with some acknowledgements,
most prominently the Ministry
of Heritage and Culture
which has been so gracious
to us in permitting
and supporting our research.
Professor McCorriston who was
my mentor as a graduate student
and has really played a
tremendous role in sort
of training and mentoring
me throughout my career.
Ohio State University,
I really can't go
on to thank enough the
very large number of people
that have been involved in
this work over the years.
And, the individuals with the
Ministry of Heritage and Culture
at John Hopkins University,
of course NASA
for funding support
for this work.
And, of course, the people
of the Sultanate of Oman,
which have been so tremendously
friendly and gracious
and welcoming us and helping us
learn about the amazing history
of this tremendous region.
So, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Moderator: Thank
you, Dr. Harrower,
and indeed the whole panel,
such wonderful presentations.
We have a few minutes
for some questions.
So--
>> Audience Member:
Well, thank you all.
That was really a very,
very exciting panel.
I have a question.
Everyone has been speaking out
the copper and copper smelting
and the trade in copper.
And, yet when one talks
about material objects very
little is said about any
of them being made of copper.
I'm wondering why, or in
what form was the copper used
in the region?
>> Dr. Michael Harrower:
Yeah, this is really one
of the most fascinating
aspects of Omani archaeology
and Omani history
being, you know,
one of the ancient world's most
prominent sources of copper.
So, we know through
an understanding
of even modern copper mining
and production in Oman today
that the Al-Hajar Mountains
are really a rich source
of this material.
How that originally gets started
during the early Bronze Age is a
matter of a lot of
research and a lot of study.
How people learned to, you
know, create the furnaces
and the temperatures to melt
this, to alloy it together
with other metals
like arsenic and tin.
And, so there's some
tremendous research involved
in that early study.
We know that perhaps they were
boring on some technologies
that were used to make
pottery in kilns, right,
to produce the temperatures
to fire pottery
and maybe elaborated from that.
Oman, as it was mentioned
earlier,
is really a center point of
trade and interconnectivity,
so they were drawing on
interaction and knowledge
and technology from a
variety of different sources.
But, it's an ongoing
real mystery about where
that technology and know-how
originates and spreads.
>> Dr. Krista Lewis: If I
could just add one little point
to that.
If I understood the question,
is why are the objects
not made of copper?
Copper is one of the
constituents of bronze,
so the copper was
in the objects,
but they had another
level of the technology
that is still being studied
to transform that raw material
into a harder material.
When you alloy it it
becomes much harder.
>> Audience Member: Yes,
a question for Dr. Lewis.
You had a illustration of
numerous objects that have been
on Earth, and one was a small
brass coin with a square center,
appears to be probably
Chinese origin.
Have you made a determination
as to the date of this coin,
the emperor of China
that it represents,
and any other significance
it might have?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Dr. Krista Lewis: Okay, that
particular coin was excavated
by one of the previous
archaeologists at the site,
so I'm actually not sure if
that particular coin has a date.
I mean, one of the challenges
with all of the coins
that are coming from this site
is they're highly corroded,
because they were
right on the sea side.
And, so the metal, which is
often in bad shape as we've seen
from archaeological sites,
and this site is
particularly damaged.
So, it's really difficult
to actually get,
even once they're
chemically cleaned,
to be able to identify
the markings on it.
So, a lot of the coins
are identified more based
on their shape and
general material,
but the inscriptions are not
always easy to read I guess.
>> Moderator: Well,
I have a question.
From this panel and the
previous panel, it's obvious
that the world has been
interconnected for quite --
for thousands of years.
How typical is Oman
for that region as far
as being the cross roads
of trade and so forth?
Like, how does it compare
to neighboring countries
or neighboring--
>> Dr. Krista Lewis: A typical?
>> I mean, is it an
extreme example or is it a--
[ Inaudible ]
>> Dr. Krista Lewis: I think
I would answer by saying
that we see -- we've
seen a lot of traffic
across different
cultural groups.
One of the things that has
struck me, and I come back
to my point about
pastoralists being the majority
of the Omanis who've lived,
is that some of those sites
that we're looking
at show no evidence,
or limited evidence,
of interaction.
So, I think it's very variable
across the different populations
whether they were on the coast
or inland or mobile or settled.
I think you would find a
great deal of variability,
as you would in some of
the surrounding regions.
Probably Dr. Kneuer could answer
that about the Indus
area as well.
>> Dr. Michael Harrower: Yeah,
to sort of respond a little bit
to that, I mean,
in a contemporary world
people are really interested
in globalization, right?
What are the forces
that have created the
interconnected world?
And, we think of social
networks and social media
and the internet as
interconnecting the world.
And, in a different way that
also happens in the past, right?
And, archaeologists
are also interested
in ancient globalization
and ancient social networks.
Like, what are the
forces early on that lead
to interconnectivity
up and down the gulf?
What are the economic,
political, religious forces
that shape the ancient
middle east, right?
And, there's a tremendous
amount to be learned, I think,
about looking back
at the time depth
that archaeology
can offer, right?
So, rather than being just
a Sunday afternoon pastime
or something we could
do for fun,
and archaeology certainly is
fun, it also has a more --
much more serious role to play
in understanding
geopolitics, right?
And, in thinking about the
lessons that can be drawn
about the underlying causes of
war and conflict, and the rise
and fall of different
geopolitical actors in the past.
So, that I think is
among the types of topics
that really get archaeologists
excited to think
about what lessons can we learn
about those sorts of patterns
from the ancient past?
And, there are indeed, you know,
many, many insights to be drawn.
>> Moderator: Thank you.
>> Dr. Krista Lewis: I could
just pick up really briefly
on what Dr. Harrower was saying,
and just extend that point
by saying, you know, while in
some respects you could say
that Oman is not
unique in this, right?
For some place to be
connected globally
to all these other places it
means those other places have
to be also in turn
connected globally.
But, I think what we're seeing
with the increasing amounts
of research that are
showing the local specificity
of those patterns, and
who they're reaching,
and who they're not reaching.
Or, how maybe the effects
of this global interconnection
are reaching even to groups
that are far from
direct contact.
In a way, what we're
doing is helping
to decolonize our scholarship,
and think beyond the idea,
that is rather old fashioned
now, that certain central areas
of the world were
important, more powerful,
and that other people
were peripheral,
less civilized if you will.
And, I think this kind of
more nuanced understanding
of what was happening
everywhere, and the really sort
of dynamic way that people
were engaging, or choosing now
to engage with the people
around them helps us, you know,
in this -- you know,
just follows what my
colleagues were saying.
Helps us understand also today's
patterns, and warns us not
to look at certain regions
of the world and say,
"You're not important.
You're not connected.
You're not in these
patterns," because it's --
we're all interconnected,
and understanding
how that's happened
in the past I think is --
definitely gives us
a view to the future.
>> Joan Weeks: Welcome
to our third panel today
about the modern cultural
tourism of ancient sites.
What a wonderful concept.
I hope by the end of this panel
that we are all ready
to do exactly that.
Take our own tourism
opportunities to visit some
of these ancient sites.
I know I'd love to do that,
but it is a very
delicate balancing act
between cultural
heritage, preservation
of these fragile sites, and
the promotion of tourism.
And, this is something that the
Omani government is dedicated
to doing, and is trying
to preserve this rich
cultural heritage,
but also make these fantastic
sites available, because it is
such a fantastic opportunity
and builds knowledge
and appreciation of the
cultural heritage of Oman.
So, I'm Joan Weeks, I'm head
of the Near East section here
at the Library of Congress,
and it's my great pleasure
to introduce this first
presentation on frameworks
for preservation, tourism, and
relevance by Dr. Nathan Reigner.
Nathan Reigner is a consulting
social scientist and principal
of Recreation and
Tourism Science LLC.
Dr. Reigner has collaborated
with federal and state parks
and forest agencies
as well as NGOs
in the United States and abroad.
During his 12 years of parks
research, Dr. Reigner has worked
in more than 50 units of
the national parks system.
Additionally, he provides
technical assistance
on visitor use management
to the nature reserve
and natural park systems
of the Russian Federation,
public and private outdoor
recreation areas in Iceland,
and nature-based
tourism destinations
in the Sultanate of Oman.
Dr. Reigner is 2018s Sultan
Qaboos Cultural Center
research fellow.
He holds an MS in
forestry from Richmond --
or, from Virginia Polytechnic
Institute and State University,
and his PHD in natural resources
from the University of Vermont,
Rubenstein School
of Environmental
and Natural Resources.
Please welcome Dr.
Reigner to the podium.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Nathan Reigner: Thank
you all for having me today.
My name's Nathan Reigner.
I'd like to thank her
excellency, the ambassador
of the Sultan Qaboos Cultural
Center, the Library of Congress,
for helping to make this
conference possible.
I have learned a lot today.
I hope to continue to learn
throughout the afternoon.
And, I want to preface my
remarks with the statement
that I have not yet
been to Oman.
I am one of the SQCCs
research fellows for 2018.
I'm very happy about that.
I'm honored by that.
My fellow fellow, Bess
Perry [assumed spelling],
is very happy about that as
well, and, so what I hope to do
with you today is share
some of the framework,
some of the foundations
that we have used
in the US national park
system, particularly
in cultural heritage sites for
the US national park system,
that inform our perspective,
and that we hope to take with us
to Oman as we work on our
research fellowship in
and around Al-Saleel
National Park.
I could not have asked
for a better introduction
to this remarks.
Well, that was a very
lovely introduction.
Thank you, but her excellency
this morning made a statement
that was just perfect
for putting my interests
and the remarks that I'll share
with you today into perspective.
She said to us that, "We want
to maintain these
treasures while sharing them
with the world."
And, that's the basic tension
that I see at the center
of tourism to cultural sites,
and I hope that some of ideas
that I share with
you today can help us
to all advance that cause.
So, protected areas --
you're going to hear me use
the word protected area.
You're going to hear
me use the word park.
In this context, we're
talking about the types
of archaeological and
cultural heritage sites
that we've been discussing
today.
They're mission oriented.
Once these places are
designated by the government,
they're dedicated to
preservation, they're dedicated
to helping people learn about
culture, and they're dedicated
to helping people enjoy and
celebrate their cultures.
But, these places
are often also --
are also often marked
by competing objectives,
objectives for protection,
objectives for economic
development,
objectives for different
types of uses
that create some tensions around
the management of these places
that need to be addressed.
So, as I mentioned our
research fellowship is going
to be centered on
Al-Saleel National Park.
I have the location.
Al-Saleel is a gazelle
breeding facility.
It is -- my understanding is
that it is relatively
newly designated,
and right now management
approaches are being developed
and created for this place.
Al-Saleel National
Park lies along many
of the most popular
routes tourists take
when they're in Oman.
We can see it in these -- in
each of these maps, Google maps,
that people have posted
about their tourism routes,
Al-Saleel National Park is
located on each of these.
Right now it's a relatively
small facility without a lot
of developed infrastructure
for visitors or tourists to use
or to support their stays.
And, so we hope to use
our research fellowship
to make some recommendations
on how Al-Saleel can develop
in a way that supports
the tourism economy,
that protects the culture, that
protects the natural heritage
of the place, and
that engages in --
engages local communities
in that process.
There are a few basic
foundations
that we're going
to bring to this.
One is the concept of relevance.
Another is the concept
of objective based --
what is called objective
based adaptive management,
and I'll talk to you a
little bit about that.
Objective based adaptive
management can help us know what
needs to be done to
protect these sites
and to facilitate their use.
And, then while we're working on
this we want to do it in a way
that cultivates a
diversity of experiences
and reflects the general
democratic purposes
of these places.
So, those are the concept
we'll go over, but let's talk
about relevance first.
When I talk about relevance
in terms of protected areas,
particularly cultural
heritage spaces,
I'm talking about
having deep and broad
and lasting connections between
protected areas, park sites,
or heritage sites
and their managers,
visitors to these places, and
the communities that live in
and around these places.
These connections are the
product of shared goals
when done correctly,
but building these connections
can often highlight some
of the tensions or
competing objectives
that we talked about earlier.
Sometimes relevance is an
easy thing to accomplish.
Jazz National Historical
Park is a historical site
in New Orleans, Virginia,
dedicated to celebrating
the idea of jazz,
a uniquely American art form.
It's easy for Jazz National
Historical site to be relevant.
Who here listens to jazz?
Every hand should be up.
We feel it as part of our lives.
It's still very much
part of the community
in which Jazz National
Historical site is located.
My -- where's my
Arkansas friend?
Hot Springs National Park
in Arkansas is having
a little bit more
of a challenge with relevancy.
Hot Springs National Park
preserves some natural features,
but it also preserves a set
of spa or health, sort of,
medical baths that were
really part of the hay day
of Hot Springs 100 years ago.
And, we don't exactly
practice health the way we used
to practice health
100 years ago.
And, so connecting
relevantly between the park
and the population
in Hot Springs,
Arkansas, is a challenge.
Gates of the Arctic National
Park up in Alaska has a --
faces relevance challenges,
but for different reasons.
It house resources like
bears and caribou, salmon,
and indigenous communities and
their subsistence practices
that we all value, however
virtually nobody goes there,
and it's impossible to get to.
And, so how do you keep a place
that is very physically distant
from a population relevant?
These are some of
the challenges.
We hope to explore relevance
and provide some guidance
to enhance the relevance
of Al-Saleel National Park
with a multi-phase, sort of,
multiple methods
research project,
where we will be interviewing
communities, stake holders
around Al-Saleel National Park,
as well as leaders in Muscat.
We'll be asking these
individuals to participate
in structured interviews
from which we'll be
gleaning social network data
about both connections
that could make
for strong partnerships,
and obstacles that need
to be overcome for
partnerships to develop.
And, we'll be doing that using
spatially explicit methods
with participatory GIS, mapping
these connections on the ground.
Bess, my fellow fellow, is
-- she is the relevant one.
She knows this much
more than I do,
but as far as I'm concerned
the important part of this is
that this is a process.
It's about determining what
our goals are, finding ways
for our goals to align, and
then moving forward based
on those common objectives.
Once we have those common
objectives established we can
move into an objectives-based
management framework.
So, I often work in
wilderness settings, wildlands,
mountain national
parks where, like,
solitude is one of
the objectives.
We want people to go out and
have solitude in the wilderness,
which is great, but
how does a manager
of a site manage for solitude?
How do they measure solitude?
Can they count -- well,
there's one solitude over here
and three solitudes
over there, and,
so we must be doing a
better job over here.
It's very difficult.
So, once we have these
goals or objectives defined
in conceptual, broad,
narrative terms we need
to find quantifiable,
measurable,
manageable variables, proxy
variables, that we can use
to measure these objectives.
And, then we have
to set the threshold
that help us evaluate whether we
are accomplishing our management
goals or not.
And, I have a little story here
about how we went about doing
that at Castillo de San Marcos,
which is a historical park
at St. Augustine, Florida,
the first masonry
structure still existent --
the oldest masonry structure
still existent in North America.
Something like that.
Not mason -- right, because
there are the pyramids
in meso-America,
things like that.
It has a first for some reason,
and we're very proud
of it for that.
It is a star fort.
It was built for the Spanish.
It is a beautiful
place to visit.
It is designated to preserve the
architectural characteristics,
and to interpret the
history of colonial Florida,
both the Spanish and English
histories as well as the history
of the Native Americans
who lived in Florida
and interacted with the fort.
One of the key ways that
the National Park Service
and Castillo de San Marcos
accomplished this mission is
through education, through
engagement of people.
There are displays.
There are reenactments,
and visitors
to this site learn quite a
lot, except when it's crowded.
When there are too
many people coming
to the site it's virtually
impossible to engage
with the education material.
This site is visited by a lot
of school groups,
which is wonderful.
Those school groups
can learn a lot,
but also those large
groups moving
through in an organized manner
can inhibit citizen visitors,
individual visitors, from
learning and engaging.
And, all of this
is a big challenge
for Castillo de San Marcos
to accomplish its goal.
So, if their objective is for
people to be able to engage
with the interpretive
information and learn about
and appreciate the history
of Castillo de San Marcos
and its role in the modern
world, we need measurable,
manageable variables
to see whether we're
accomplishing our objective.
Well, one of the variables
that we hit on was the number
of people in any given area
of the fort at one time.
That variable is hard to
collect, but what is easy
to do is to count the number
of people entering this fort.
There's a door counter.
It takes a click for
every person who enters.
We can correlate statistically
after collecting
some field data here,
some of our great field
assistants collecting some field
data, we can correlate
the number of entrees
into Castillo de San
Marcos, the relationship
that those entries have to
the number of people standing
in front of the signs
at any one time.
And, we can say, "Okay, we
want at least 50 percent
of the people to be
able to read the signs,
so we need to keep our numbers
less than 50 on the Y axis here.
That means that we can
have about 150 people
at any one time entering
this site if we want
to accomplish our
management goal
of people being able
to read the signs."
So, we were able to
take that information,
plot it against the
overall use of this site,
figure out the days and times
in which this site is sort
of overused in terms
of being able to engage
with the interpretive material
and provide some guidance
to national park
service about what to do
to address this situation.
So, that's our -- so we have --
relevance is based upon
shared objectives and goals.
We have our identified goal,
in this case of being able
to engage with the
interpretive information.
We're able to measure that --
our progress of that
against that goal
and determine whether
we're achieving it or not
without indicators
and thresholds.
But, then what do we
do about it, right?
We found out we're
either successful,
or if we're failing we should
do something about this.
We need to take some
management action.
Well, most often the management
action that I see in places
like this is, well, we need to
decrease the demand being placed
on these places, and we do that
by limiting the amount of use.
It is potentially affective,
but in some ways it sabotages us
in trying to accomplish
our goal.
If our goal is to get people
to engage, if our goal is
to share them with the world,
limiting the number of people
who can come into these
places is not going
to help us achieve that.
So, I want to highlight
that there are a number
of other strategies and tactics
or strategies and actions
that can be taken to
address these situations.
We don't need to just
decrease the demand.
We can increase the
supply at these places.
At Castillo de San Marcos
instead of decreasing the demand
for reading signs, what
if we increase the number
of signs that there were?
Or, increase the number of
programs, or put up some lights
and let people in at night and
expanded the amount of time
that people could visit?
We can harden the resources to
be more resistant to damages.
We can adapt visitor
behavior to be less impactful,
and we can do this with
any number of actions,
and I have an example here
from Mesa Verde National Park
about how this happened there.
So, Mesa Verde, a Puebloan
settlement, now protected,
one of the first national
parks established,
one of the first national parks
national monuments established
with the Antiquities Act,
preserved cliff dwellings
and other archaeological
sites as well as petroglyphs.
And, this place is
facing some problems.
It's facing problems
with its historic
and cultural resources
associated
with inappropriate
use, graffiti, theft,
and some of this use is
starting to affect the integrity
of the sites themselves.
And, so Parks Service here
has established a set of rules
and regulations, and
they enforce them
with active law enforcement,
and the way they do this is
by requiring all
visitors to enter the site
with a National Park
Service guide.
So, we have a rule that says
that visitors are welcome
to the site, but only under the
guidance of a trained ranger,
and if you don't follow
this rule you are punishable
under the law.
And, this law enforcement
and rule
and regulation has been coupled
with a rationing
allocation scheme,
the size of the tour groups
that can go in is calibrated not
to exceed the maximum allowable,
and by education programs
that help educate people why
these rules are necessary,
which helps to gain
compliance with them.
And, this is all
within a zoning regime,
so that only the
most sensitive sites
within the park require this
guided tour, while other,
less sensitive areas of the
park are open without that guide
to provide a diversity
of opportunities.
And, so this diversity
of opportunities is the
fourth foundational framework
that we'll be bringing with
us to our work with Al-Saleel,
the idea of opportunity spectra.
That protected areas exist along
a range, many ranges in fact,
from urban to wild, from
developed to primitive,
from high use to ow use,
from highly regulated
to less highly regulated, from
closer to cities to further away
from cities, all kinds
of different spectra.
And, I think if we're
doing a good job
at managing our cultural
heritage sites then we have a
diversity of different
types of sites.
And, the San Antonio Missions
National Historical Park,
also a world heritage
site in Texas,
I think does a good job
of illustrating that.
This is a chain of
missions that runs
down the San Antonio
River south of the city,
and there are many different
missions along the way.
There are primitive,
small missions
that have not been restored.
There are larger missions
that have been restored.
There are recreational
opportunities
that link these missions.
There are sacred services
that are still conducted
within these missions
that are in line
with their original
establishment,
and these missions as a whole
park are managed not just
for historical preservation, but
also for wildlife preservation
and ecological quality
along the San Antonio River.
So, I think the San Antonio
River has done a good job
of providing a diversity
of opportunities
along this corridor.
And, one of the key things the
we were interested in doing
with Al-Saleel National
Park is helping it fit
within the diversity of
tourism opportunities in Oman.
Oman has a diversity of
cultural heritage sites
that we've heard about today.
It has a diversity of
natural heritage sites,
it has a diversity of
other opportunities
that will draw tourists
to the country
and help the world realize
what a wonderful place Oman is.
And, so we look forward to
bringing these foundations
of relevance of the objectives
and indicators based approach
and the opportunities spectra
concept to Oman in our research.
And, I look forward --
one of the things I look forward
here today, both with the rest
of the panel and in the
discussion afterwards,
is hearing about your ideas
about how we can apply these
and other concepts to our work
in Al Saleel when we're there.
Thank you very much
for your time.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: Thank you so
much, Dr. Nathan Reigner.
That was fascinating.
I think we see a
pathway forward,
and this is really going
to be a great opportunity
for developing tourism in Oman.
And, to continue on with this
theme I really love this one.
Traveling the sands of time, a
foray into cultural heritage.
Tourism in the Sultanate of Oman
by Dr. Christopher Thornton.
Christopher Thornton
is the senior director
of cultural heritage of the
National Geographic Society
where he oversees grants
and programs in archeology,
anthropology, paleoanthropology,
and human geography.
After lecturing at
George Mason University,
Dr. Thornton joined the
National Geographic in 2010
to oversee the research
grants program.
In addition to his role
in advising the National
Geographic Society
and National Geographic
Media on issues related
to cultural heritage,
Dr. Thornton sits
on the US Commission to
UNESCO and is director
of the UNESCO world
heritage site of Bat in Oman.
He's an expert in the
origins of metallurgy
and early complex
societies in Iran and Arabia.
Dr. Thornton holds a
PHD in anthropology
from the University
of Pennsylvania.
Please welcome him
to the podium.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Christopher
Thornton: Thank you.
I should shorten that
bio a little bit I think.
Let me start by saying thank
you to the Library of Congress
and the Sultan Qaboos
Cultural Center
for this wonderful opportunity.
I was -- in the coffee
break I was talking to some
of my colleagues, and I'm pretty
confident this is the very first
time in history that all
of the American archeology
teams working in Oman have been
in the same place talking
about their projects.
And, I'd like to
throw it out there
that this has actually been
an amazing opportunity for us
to hear what each
other is doing,
and America is actually
growing force
in cultural heritage in Oman.
When Joy and Dr. Cable
and I first started
in Oman there were only three
projects run by Americans,
and it was heavily dominated
by the French and the Italians,
and the Germans, sorry,
Olivie [assumed spelling].
And, nowadays, I would say
that American teams are some
of the strongest and the largest
teams in Oman and are a major,
major training grounds for
students to learn archeology
but also to learn
about the Middle East,
not just from America
but students from all
over the world come to
work on American projects.
So, I throw to you Sultan
Qaboos Cultural Center to think
about how we can maybe
continue this dialogue
and working together
to kind of fuse this.
So with that I will follow
Dr. Reigner by saying
that I'm not an expert
in tourism.
I'm an archeologist but unlike
Dr. Reigner I have been to Oman,
and I was very lucky to
for two years be involved
in a tourism effort in Oman,
bringing mainly American
tourists.
So, instead of talking
about the Bat project
which I'm happy to
do afterwards.
Dr. Cable and Dr. Soritas
[assumed spelling] my
co-directors are also
here, so we can tag team
if people have questions
about the Bat project.
I thought I would just
talk about this example
that we ran a project for two
years that had some success
and some failures,
but we learned a lot
about what it takes to run
a cultural heritage tourism
program in the Sultanate of
Oman, and I wanted to kind
of share that with
all of you today.
So, any of you who've
been to Muscat know
that this is what a
tourist looks like, right?
So, they're mainly
European tourists who come
in off the cruise ships, and
they come into Muttrah and they,
you know, pour off
the cruise ships
and they ransack all the
Indian and Chinese goods
in the Muttrah Souq, and then
they get back on the ships.
And, all the Pakistanis,
and Bangladeshis,
and the Belujis [phonetic] are,
like, you know, swirling around,
and that's it, and
that's tourism, right?
And, it has almost zero
benefits for the country.
These people say,
"I've been to Oman."
Great, check, right?
Occasionally, the slightly
better tourists are the ones
that come for this,
and they come and stay
at these luxurious resorts,
traditionally in Muscat,
you know, the Shetty
and the Shangri-La
and all these wonderful
places I can't afford,
and nowadays actually
Salalah, if any of you've been,
there's some wonderful
resorts down at Salalah.
So, all of this is for the good.
It brings them there for longer,
and occasionally
they leave the beach,
and they do little
day trips, right?
So, they hire a tourism company
through the hotel to drive them
out to Nizwa Fort, and they
walk through Nizwa Fort
with no guide, and they
saw, "Wow, that was neat.
Let's go back to the beach."
Right? That's tourism in Oman
right now, the vast majority
of tourism, and I think
everybody here knows
that doesn't work, right?
So, this is the challenges
facing you,
Dr. Reigner, welcome.
And, so it was a
funny coincidence
that just a few years ago I
collided with two now-friends,
one of them Dr. Jeffrey Rose.
He's known to many of you.
He's an archeologist,
American who,
he and his wife have now
been based in Oman for many,
many years, and he runs
a project in Dhofar.
He became a National
Geographic Explorer the year
after a Palestinian became an
explorer who's a specialist
in conflict resolution
and tourism,
that is how do you use
tourism to bring interfaith
and intercultural dialogue?
So, the three of us
were probably staying
up far too late,
and we were talking
about what potential there
was in Oman for the kinds
of projects that Aziz Abu Sarah
had been running for many years
in the holy land
very successfully.
So, I pointed out
that the funny thing
about Oman is it has a chain
of UNESCO world heritage sites
and potential sites like
Salut and other, Qalhat,
all in the Northern
part of Oman,
and there's that beautiful
Sultan Qaboos Highway
that runs all the way
across to the Emirates.
So, it's actually very
easy to access these sites
if you know what
you're looking for,
and it would be a very
easy overland expedition.
And, we started looking
into it and realized
that there's not a single tour
company in the world that run,
at that time, ran an overland
expedition for tourists
through the center of Northern
Oman and into the Emirates.
There were tour groups that
go to Oman, and then they go
to Dubai or they go to
Oman, they go to Salalah.
Sometimes they go to
Nizwa, sometime, you know,
they hop around but none of
them just go through the country
to actually see the real
Oman, right, and those of you
from Muscat know what I mean
by the real Oman, right?
So, we thought this was a
really great opportunity.
So, we approached our
colleagues in the travel office,
National Geographic Expeditions,
of course believes in the power
of science, exploration,
and storytelling to
change the world.
I'm not staff in the expeditions
side of the house as you heard.
I'm on the nonprofit side, but
the three of us went to them,
and we bullied them, and we
said, "Look, we need your help.
We'd like to try this out.
We'd like to experiment."
They had said, "You know, we
looked at it in years past,
and there wasn't even
a company on the ground
that we could partner
with to make this happen."
So, Aziz said, "Well, my
company, which is based
in Jerusalem, will find
partners on the ground in Oman
and will make it happen."
And they said, "If you can do
it, then we'll make it happen."
Well, luckily Aziz is amazing,
and he couldn't be here today.
He actually lives in
DC, but Mejdi Tours,
I just want to give a shout
out, is a really amazing company
that -- they've won a number
of international awards.
They work in places
as diverse as Columbia
where they bring tourists to
meet with the FARC as well
as government representatives.
They've been running in Israel
and Palestine for over a decade.
At every site in
Israel Palestine
that you visit you will
have a Jewish Israeli guide,
and you will have an
Arab Israeli guide
and sometimes a Christian
as well, a Christian Arab,
and you'll get multiple
perspectives
on every site that you visit.
And, the point of it interfaith
and intercultural dialogue,
and people come away
completely changed in the way
that they think about
the world, right?
So, Aziz said I can do this
in Oman with your help,
and luckily, Jeff
Rose's wife, Maggie,
is absolutely brilliant
and a tour organizer.
So, we had someone on the
ground who could help.
[Inaudible] Yeah, I know Maggie.
She's a little bit like this.
She would organize
this whole room
into color coordination
if you let her.
So, we were very, very lucky
to have this incredible team
on the ground, and
we made it work.
So, the purpose of the trip
and remember National Geographic
trips are intentionally designed
to be educational, so
we really, really --
and we don't give a test
at the end but we might,
but they're very
educationally driven.
And, it's -- we really
believe in the power of tourism
to change the world, right, that
tourism can make a difference
in how people approach their
fellow humans and other places.
So, the three of us had sort
of three different reason.
I'm number one, right?
So, I'm an archeologist,
and I wanted people
to understand the rise and
fall of urban civilizations
through time, and I think Oman
and the Emirates combined is a
really, really wonderful place
to see this, because it is
a traditionally marginal
environment that is the
environment is not generally
conducive for large
urban civilization.
And, yet multiple times
throughout history,
starting in the Bronze Age
to today you've seen the
rise of major cities.
So, how does that happen
and also I should note the
collapse of major cities?
So, we wanted to
kind of look at that.
Aziz was very keen,
obviously, to bring Americans
to understand what is an Arab.
How diverse are the Arab people?
What is Islam?
How diverse is Islam?
And to learn more about
the Middle East other
than what they see on
Fox News or god forbid,
you know, whatever else.
And, then third, and
this is definitely
for those who know Jeff Rose.
It was to experience the
natural beauty of Oman
to really know what it
means, to be in the desert,
to be in the mountains,
to be on the coast,
and to really experience
everything that Oman has
to offer which is
of course a lot.
So, I'm just going
to zoom through this.
I can always send this to
people who are interested
to know what the itinerary was,
but just quickly I
shall start there.
We would start in the East,
and people could either do
a hike-up the Wadi Shab.
People forget there is standing
beautiful water in Oman.
You can do a hike-up
the Wadi Shab or if --
for the older, particularly
people who are disabled
or older, they would go
to the Bimah Sinkhole,
and then we would
go look at Qalhat.
We did not walk on Qalhat,
because that is not allowed,
but we would look at Qalhat, and
we'd talk about what Qalhat was
and why it was important.
Sorry. Then we would
do Muscat of course.
We'd show them the modern city.
We would talk about how Sultan
Qaboos, in his great vision,
saw a way to modernize
the capitol
without creating a monstrosity,
allowing the culture of Oman
to come forth in the capitol
in a really beautiful way.
I will give a shout out
to the visitor center
at the Grand Mosque.
If any of you have been --
go there and have not been to
meet the women who volunteer
and work in that visitor
center, it is absolutely a must.
They are incredible.
They're Omanis who volunteer
their time to talk to tourists
about whatever awkward
questions they might ask,
and they're really wonderful.
And, we had multiple, multiple
American, particularly women,
ask very difficult
questions, you know,
"Does your husband
let you drive?"
and, you know, these women
would laugh and laugh I mean,
you know, but a lot of the
American women who came
on our trips would literally
be in tears by the end of it,
because just their whole
worldview of an Islamic
or an Arab woman was
completely altered,
and that was very powerful.
So, huge shout out, because
I think they do a really
wonderful job.
We'd then go into the
mountains, go into real Oman,
and we would go to Misfah, into
other of these mud work villages
up in the mountains to
experience the Falaj system.
We would talk about the al
Falaj and how it was created
and what means and how it
creates these beautiful,
beautiful paradises
up in the mountains,
talk about traditional
farming practices.
And, what was really wonderful
is some of these villages
which are still reserved,
they have tiny,
tiny little eco lodges run by
families and very few people,
usually just Germans and
Poles, know about them,
but they would welcome us,
and they would give us a walking
tour through their village
and then host us for dinner.
And, it was such a
magical connection
that most tourists don't have in
Oman that is meeting real Omanis
in their homes and
talking to them about life
in these beautiful
mediaeval villages.
You have to go Nizwa, of
course, the sort of cultural
and particularly the
religious heart of the country,
and we would talk about that.
We'd talk about the
two capitols, right,
Muscat being the political
and economic capitol
and Nizwa being the cultural
and religious capitol,
do the for, as you must.
But, I always love taking
people to Bahla, right,
one of the world's largest
mud work structures,
recently restored thanks
to the Italians and UNESCO
and others, [inaudible].
Bahla is interesting for
those who have been there,
because the restauration
is absolutely beautiful,
and there is not a single sign.
You have absolutely no idea
what you're looking at.
There's not even guides.
So, it's not like you
could ask someone.
So, I did as much research as
I could do and my fellow guides
to give them as much
information as we could,
but for a UNESCO world
heritage site that is
so gorgeous we need signage.
I mean, just one
sign would help.
We would go from there
to the Al-Ayn Tombs
which luckily don't
need much of a sign,
because they're just gorgeous
but we would explain
what we were looking at.
Obviously, these 5000 year old
tombs never have been restored
and in perfect condition
which is really wonderful,
and amazingly, tourists
really connect with those.
Tourists really,
for some reason,
it brings the archeology
alive in a way
that I always find amusing.
I'm not sure why.
I guess we're just
-- we work there.
So, for us it's like,
"Yeah, the tombs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah."
And they just go, "Wow.
These are incredible."
So go down to Al-Ayn.
We then take them to Bat, right?
So, I've been working at that
with Dr. Cable and Soritas
and others who are here
for almost a decade
or over a decade now, and
we've done a lot of research.
We've done a lot of
community outreach,
a lot of education
programs, and we have a lot
of Wasta [assumed spelling],
as they say, in Bat,
and we're very proud of that.
The people of Bat have always
welcomed us, but we struggle
to find ways to bring the
site to life for tourists.
Actually Charlie Cable
is working with a group,
with the World Monument
Fund kind of think
of a strategic plan for the
site which is really important
but without someone
like one of us there,
there is absolutely no point
in bringing tourists to Bat,
and again, it's a world
heritage site, right?
With one of us there or
with one of the local Omanis
who we have trained, who
have worked with us for years
and years, and they're
brilliant and wonderful.
With one of them there it
brings the site to life, right?
So, it's finding a way
to connect tourists
with these people
who are trained,
who know what they're looking
at and can help explain it,
it makes a huge difference.
We then would cross the border
which is always a very
interesting experience
for tourists.
They're always shocked
by how different it is,
and that difference
is really important,
because it shows the
diversity of the Arab nations,
that they're not all the same,
"the Gulf Arabs", you know,
they're all just one thing.
It's really important we
felt to cross that border
and experience a different
part of the Arabian Peninsula.
Obviously, we'd go
Hili, the Al Ain Museum
which is a wonderful collection.
Now, we have the
National Museum in Muscat,
so we don't need the Al Ain
Museum as much, and then we'd go
for a little bit
of luxury, right?
So, the Al Maha Desert Resort
is a wonderful example.
Dr. Reigner, I would encourage
you to at least research it,
if you don't want to pay
the 1000 dollars a night.
But, it is a wonderful
eco lodge.
It is a protected
area that they --
it's a breeding area for
gazelles and the oryx,
and they have created what is
a fairly sustainable lodge.
National Geographic
will generally only work
with sustainable eco lodges.
They have a number
of international certifications
and sustainability.
They use solar energy, they
recycle water etcetera,
etcetera, but it's that
wonderful combination of tourism
and preserving a
natural landscape,
including breeding programs.
So, that was a really
nice example
that I never saw the
equivalent in Oman
but the potential is huge.
We then would go to Abu Dhabi.
We would go to the Grand Mosque.
We would go on a dhow to
talk about the coral reefs
of the Gulf and how
they've been affected
by development and
modernization.
Many people don't know there
are coral reefs in this region.
The coral reefs in the South are
actually way better preserved
and way more interesting,
Southern --
in Dhofar for example.
But, people rarely know
about them, so we try to talk
about that ecology, and
finally we'd end up in Dubai,
and a lot of people say, "God,
why would you end in Dubai?"
Well, first of all believe it
or not tourists know Dubai,
and so you can sell the trip
on the idea that you're going
to give them an educational
tour of Dubai.
You're not going to casinos.
You're not doing any of that.
You're talking about Emirati
culture and the growth of Dubai.
National Geographic
did a whole documentary
about the Burj Khalifa and the
construction and what it meant
for the future of Dubai
about five years ago,
and we talk about that.
We actually end the trip at
the very top, the VIP lounge
at the Burj Khalifa, looking out
over Dubai which, of course, is,
you know, one of the world's
great 21st century cities
in terms of modernization
and all of the stuff,
and I say to them, I always say
to them, "Look at what you see.
5000 years ago this is what
Bat kind of looked like."
It had towers.
It had these, you
know, monuments.
It was kind of the same and
look at the way Bat is now.
So, in 5000 years Dubai
is going to be nothing,
and that's what archeology
tells you, right?
It's about rise and
fall of civilizations.
You can never take
things for granted.
So, we talk about
sustainability.
How do you make these
cities sustainable,
so they last a little bit longer
than they would otherwise,
right?
Powerful messages that this part
of the world explicitly can tell
that very few other
places in the world can.
Tourists loved it
generally speaking.
People had a great time
but these were definitely
adventurous tourists.
They were tourists who have been
to every other place on the map,
and this was an area they
had never seen before.
So, they were willing to
go a little bit off-road
and try something
new, which was great.
We also, and just to throw out
there being National Geographic,
we do run photography tours,
and basically we take our
general educational tours
and we just make it basically
a week-long seminar or workshop
about best practices in
photography and instead
of an archeologist
leading the trip,
we have one of our
photographers lead the trip
but we use the same itinerary,
and that was actually very,
very successful, because people
who are into photography,
they have a very
good eye for beauty.
They're interested in
culture and nature and all
of these things, and
there's a huge market for it.
And, Oman is, of course,
visually stunning, right,
unlike the Emirates which is
a little flat but they really,
really, got into Oman.
They really loved the natural
beauty, the culture of it.
They just found so
many opportunities.
So, that ended up being almost
more successful in terms
of sales than our
educational trips.
So, positive reactions
from the tourists,
to the person they all said
being introduced to friendly,
tolerant Arab people in the
stable and prosperous part
of the Middle East completely
changed their view of what it is
to be Arab and what the
Middle East is all about.
They felt educated
about world history
and environmentally marginal
areas, so that's good, I win.
And, they -- to just point they
really enjoyed both the natural
and the cultural beauty.
They were surprised about
the wealth of diversity
of these assets for
tourism which was great.
Now, some negative
reactions, lack of information.
I think we all know this.
This is a key, key problem.
If tourists go to sites and they
don't know what they're looking
at, they're not going to say
good things about it, right?
They're going to feel that
they've wasted their time.
They will put that online and
then nobody will go, right?
So, this is a very,
very easy way to fix it.
We've been trying in Bat
for many years to do this,
and we're going to
keep pushing for it.
Signs are the easiest and
cheapest way to do this.
We found that there was very
limited interaction normally
between tourists
and their guides,
even when the guides
were Omani and Emirati.
They didn't -- early on
when we started the trip,
the guides didn't
know how to interact
with the tourists,
so they didn't.
They were friendly.
They were polite.
They would say, "Now, we're
going to go to the Grand Mosque.
Here's the Grand Mosque."
But they didn't know
to talk about what's it
like to be Omani, right?
What is it like at home?
How did you go to school?
How did you learn to drive?
What's your favorite,
you know, football team?
These sort of things that,
again, humanize people.
They make you say,
"Omanis are just like me."
Right, and that's so
important, and they know
that in Sultan Qaboos
Cultural Center,
this is your whole mission, is
that intercultural dialogue,
and I really felt that this
is something that we can work
on with tourism in Oman
is teaching the guides how
to open up, particularly to
Americans who, as you know,
are a little overly friendly
sometimes but to learn to open
up in ways that are still
comfortable to the Omani guides
but allow the Americans to feel
like they're learning something
what it is to be Omani,
and of course tourism
infrastructure is a huge problem
particularly when you
go into the interior.
There are very few hotels
designed particularly
for high-end tourism, and
that becomes a huge problem,
because you end up having to --
we would stay at the Golden
Tulip outside of Nizwa which is
about the nicest you'll
get in the interior,
and then we would spend one
day to see all of the sites
that I just listed before
we got to the Hilih Rotana
and we go through the border.
It was a long day, because there
is not a single hotel anywhere
in that stretch.
I think in Ibri now they
have some apartment hotels
or something but
they're not a sort of --
it's not a common practice yet.
And, I think that's an
easy way to bring tourists
to the interior again
which is very helpful
for the local people.
Lessons learned, Omani guides
are actually quite rare.
They're growing, there are
schools now, university courses
to teach Omanis to be guides.
They generally know how to deal
with these tourists
coming off the boat.
They don't know how to deal
with a high-end tourist
who wants a real
authentic Omani experience,
and that's something
we worked very,
very hard with our Omani guides
to teach them how to do that,
and they were open, and these,
you know, these guides are
so smart, men and women,
Omanis are so smart
and are very well trained, and
once we just showed them how,
they took to it like that
and were really brilliant.
I should also note some
of our Omani guides were
wonderful photographers
which was a talent
that they had hidden,
but once we started doing the
photography tours, they brought
out their own cameras, and
suddenly it became a dialogue
between the Omani photographers,
the National Geographic
photographer,
and the tourist photographers,
which was a really wonderful way
to talk about how you see
things and what you photograph
and that kind of thing.
Guides are often unfamiliar
with their own sights.
This is obviously
around places like Bahla.
You won't find a
tour guide in Oman
who can actually give
you a tour of Bahla.
That's a critical,
critical problem.
There are very few local
travel companies actually run
by Omanis.
There's a number of travel
companies that are run
by Indians which is sort
of typical in the Gulf
to have the management
be Indian,
but the guides should
absolutely be Omani.
That is really, really
important,
and then this is obvious I think
but just to throw it out there.
High-end tourism is
sustainable tourism, right?
The ethos of Oman as set
by Sultan Qaboos himself was
we will modernize this country,
we will advance this country,
but not at the expense
of our heritage, and that is
of course the brilliance
of him as a leader.
If you want to do that, mass
tourism is not the answer.
There's no infrastructure for
it, and it's highly destructive
to heritage, and as we noticed
from the cruise ships
nobody benefits really.
I mean, maybe China, dumping
its products into the soup,
but nobody is really benefiting.
So, just to throw out there,
I really think the future
of Omani tourism is
this high-end tourism
where you have smaller groups
but going more in-depth,
into places like the interior
and hopefully eventually
to Dhofar which is
Jeff Rose's vision
that we would actually
get there.
So, with that thank you
all so much and happy
to answer questions later.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: Thank you
so much, Christopher.
That was very fascinating.
I'm ready to go.
So, our next presentation is
about constructing
cultural heritage,
the Jewel of Muscat
Project by Dr. Eric Staples.
Eric Staples is currently
an assistant professor
at Zayed University, Abu Dhabi
in the United Arab Emirates.
He's an interdisciplinarian,
a maritime historian whose
interests include Indian ocean
shipbuilding, seafaring,
and navigation.
In addition to his historical
pursuits he has also been
actively involved in a
variety of maritime archeology
and experimental
archeological projects.
From 2010 until 2016,
he was the director
of the Oman Maritime overseeing
different maritime heritage
projects for the
Sultanate of Oman.
Dr. Staples holds a
PHD in Islamic history
from the University of
California in Santa Barbara,
and I was just standing over
at our display and I said,
"Look at these maritime
excavations we have here
on table two."
And he says, "I did that book."
I think that's one of the
things that's so phenomenal
about our scholars today that --
and for me too, to have an
archeological site that is not
above ground but underground.
So, Dr. Staples.
>> Dr. Eric Staples:
Good afternoon.
I would like to echo my
colleagues saying thank you
first of all, Sultan
Qaboos Cultural Center,
Library of Congress,
your excellency, I think,
is no longer here,
for organizing this
event first of all.
It's been wonderful,
spectacular room.
I don't think I've ever
presented in a room
with this much gravitas I think.
But, I would also thank you
very much for inviting me.
I have a confession.
I was actually invited to
present in the second panel
of the day and talk about
maritime trade and technology
in Middle Islamic Dhofar but
then they contacted me and said,
"Would you be willing to talk
about it in the third panel."
About Jewel of Muscat, and
I said, "Sure, no problem."
But I have echo what every other
person in this panel has said.
I know nothing about
cultural tourism
or at least I thought I did
until I saw Chris's photo of me
on that cultural tour and
I said, "Wait, that's me."
I had actually engaged in
lectures on their tour,
in our experimental [inaudible].
So, well actually I know a
little bit, a small amount.
As was mentioned, I think
also lesson learned,
was write very short
introductions.
I am primarily trained
as an historian
with what you would
call sustained interest
in maritime archeology and
experimental archeology
which I'll talk a bit about
what that actually is.
And, I've had the incredible
good fortune to have worked
for eight years with a, what I'd
call, rather unique team in Oman
which was basically -- this is
where I push the
button I think --
yes, basically a team of
archeologists, originally led
by Tom Vosmer, the man
with the grey beard
and the Indiana Jones hat you
can see over there who was sort
of the founding father of study
of maritime technologies in Oman
and the Western Indian Ocean as
well as Italian archeologists,
Omani, and Indian
shipwrights, boat workers,
sail makers, model makers.
Engaged in a wide
variety of projects,
everything from designed,
developing,
and constructing museum
exhibits, oral history projects,
boat documentation projects,
maritime cultural landscape
projects, documentaries,
etcetera, the full gamut.
But, I would like today
to talk about the project
that first all sort of
gathered us together,
and this is the Jewel
of Muscat project.
But, before I get into what
the Jewel of Muscat project,
and many of you might be aware
of it, I would like to mention
that Oman is rather unique
in the Western Indian Ocean
in particular, but even in the
larger, almost global context,
in that it has engaged
in three significant,
experimental reconstruction
voyaging projects.
What I actually mean by that
is basically three projects
where experts get together.
They try to figure out
the puzzle together,
how ships that sort of enabled
all of this maritime trade
and interconnection
that everyone has talked
about so much today.
And, then basically build
them, and then try to sail them
on the historic routes
basically.
The first, as you
might recognize
from this rather grainy photo,
is the Sohar in 1980, '81,
which was actually a
very pioneering project.
Undertaken by the
Omani government,
and under the direction of
the Irish inventor and writer,
Tim Severin, who basically at
the time wanted to build a --
an hypothesis of what a
early Islamic trading vessel
that would sail to China, and
that is sort of, often sort of,
referred to in the
mythical tales of Sinbad.
And, then to actually
replicate that voyage.
And, they built a very large,
sewn plank vessel in 1980
in Sohar, Oman, an entirely
Indian team of carpenters,
shipwrights, and rope workers.
And, then sailed it in seven
and a half months in 1981
from Muscat to China with
an international crew
under the command
of Tim Severin.
A remarkable journey.
The book about it,
Sinbad Voyage,
I highly recommend you read
it if you have a chance.
Interesting, I referred to it
as an experimental
reconstruction rather
than an experimental,
archaeological reconstruction,
because the evidence
that they were basing it
on was not archaeological.
They had no archaeological
evidence to really,
reliably base itself on.
So it was basically
on very limited set
of iconography basically,
sort of, some drawings
from the 13th century as
well as drawings on some maps
and a handful of
textual references.
The second one, Magan
Boat Three, which is part
of a larger series, I
see some people smiling,
is basically what I would refer
to as an archaeological
floating hypothesis.
Putting together some
rather diverse sets
of archaeological evidence and
textual evidence to try and come
up with a working model of
what a bronze age vessel
that enabled all of this
early globalization,
as often refer to, but sort of,
what we would call,
long distance trade.
This is a composite vessel
made of reeds, reed mats, rope,
a bit of wood, a large amount of
bitumen as well as some leather,
goat hair, even for the sail.
This one, and it was
actually four have been built,
this was a third, and this was
the only one to actually try
to replicate a voyage.
It, sort of, unfortunately
sank on its way to India,
but nonetheless, what you would
call a very interesting project
that the Omani government
invested heavily in.
The third is the
Jewel of Muscat,
which I will be actually talking
about today, but before I talk
about it I find it very
interesting in talking
about cultural heritage or
archaeological heritage.
This is, I would say, rather
interesting about Oman
in the sense that it is
specifically crafting what you
would call a heritage narrative,
a maritime heritage narrative,
around experimental
reconstructions,
which are rather different than
your typical heritage narrative,
which more focused on what
you would call geographical
archaeological sites or
historical artifacts.
These are modern interpretations
that provide modern stories
of a hypothetical past, which I
also find sort of interesting,
and sort of that modern
construction of a past --
fabled past so to speak.
Now the Jewel of Muscat was
a bi-government initiative
between the Sultanate of Oman
and the government of Singapore,
basically to do something
relatively similar to the Sohar,
and build an early Islamic
sewn plank trade vessel.
And, then sail it
across the Indian Ocean.
Unlike the Sohar,
however, this was based
on archaeological evidence.
This was primarily on
the Belitung wreck,
which often referred to as
the Belitung wreck largely,
because it was found in 1998 off
Belitung Island in Indonesia.
Many of you are probably very
well aware of this wreck.
It is one of the most
significant historical wrecks
for Indian Ocean trade.
It's dated to the
Ninth Century CE,
and it has over 60,000
artifacts.
You can see here you have
some green glazed ware,
rather dramatic.
You have some of the earliest
examples of blue and white.
The vast majority, however,
are this Cheung Sha ware.
An incredible amount
of ceramics,
but you also have
other often referred
to as priceless treasures.
This cup's actually worth,
I think, 14 million dollars,
so it's not priceless, but
rather expensive, and a variety
of bronze mirrors as well.
Sort of, this cargo all
basically made in China was,
most archaeologists assume,
was on its way to west Asia
to the Islamic world to
be sold when it sank.
Now, this is very fascinating
for ceramics archaeologists
that are interested
in material culture,
but for maritime
archaeologists and historians
of maritime technology, the
real treasure was actually the
wreck itself.
This is the only historic wreck
that has been documented
and published.
There's another one,
more recent,
that's currently being studied,
but hasn't been published
in any depth yet in Thailand.
But, this is basically, sort
of, our sole example of early
to Middle Islamic maritime
trading ship that we have.
And, had the director, or I
guess the person in charge
of the second season of the
salvaging team, Michael Flecker,
who estimated there was roughly
40 percent of the whole left,
which gave us an incredible
amount of information.
It has the stem, ceiling planks
that you put the cargo on.
It has frames, sort
of the internal ribs,
planking, and beams.
But, what was even
more interesting,
and what struck the
archaeologists that was engaged
in the salvaging, it also
has sort of a wide variety
of technical detail that was
completely lacking before.
You can see here,
this is the keel.
You can see the size of holes,
where the holes are located,
the mortise in which
the stem is placed.
This provides a much more of a
viable model for reconstruction,
but even more interesting, what
was the -- Michael Flecker,
the archaeologist
who specializes
in Southeast Asian shipping and
Chinese shipping, and he said,
"This is clearly
not Southeast Asia.
This is clearly not
a Chinese vessel.
This is something
very different."
Particularly, because you
could see here it was entirely
stitched with natural
fibers, all of the planks.
There were no nails.
There was no lashed lugs like
you found in Southeast Asia,
and the entire vessel was held
together with natural fibers.
This is around 1100
year old natural fibers
with the actual ropes that
you can see stitched in this,
what we call, double
vertical X pattern.
So, the challenge of this
project was then how do you
actually reconstruct something
like this as a modern,
sort of what you would
call, replica of this.
Particularly, because this
is by government initiative.
The Sultanate of Oman
basically said, "We are going
to build this, and give this
to the people of Singapore
as a gift to showcase
with the actual artifacts
that Singapore actually bought
from the salvaging company."
And, so basically Tom Vosmer,
the man with the Indiana
Jones hat and the gray beard,
sort of was the director
of construction in Oman,
the archaeologist
that was involved
in the salvaging
Michael Flecker,
and a maritime consultant
working for the government
of Singapore, Nick
Birmingham [assumed spelling],
got together, reviewed
the evidence.
There were a lot
of gaps, though.
It was only 40 percent.
They tried to fill in the
gaps as best they could
with ethnographic evidence,
with looking at iconography,
to try and put together
basically this,
a three dimensional design,
which was then built on a one
to 15 scale model to try an
actually look, this is the type
of vessel that will be built.
One of the issues
involved with this is that,
and it's a rather
controversial collection,
being just up the road
from the Smithsonian.
The Belitung wreck actually
was not excavated due
to best practices
of archaeology.
There was not a ministry
that was over seeing it.
It was not a university
archaeology team.
What it was was basically
a salvaging company
that had bought the
rights to salvage it, and,
so what that was basically
is that there was --
Michael Flecker documented
the wreck as best he could.
But, there wasn't as much
information as if it had been,
what you would call,
excavated over years and years.
This is sort of a lost
opportunity in many ways,
but with the evidence
that we did had,
we still had an incredible
amount,
much more than we
ever had actually.
So, what was also
very interesting,
and I think what sort of eludes
to, I guess what you would call,
the material connection, these
networks of Indian Ocean trade,
was that the wood itself,
that was identified,
comes from Africa, India,
perhaps even southeast Asia.
We also have -- you
can see here,
I think it's your upper right,
is basically Afzelia africana.
That was a good portion of the
hull, which is from Africa.
We have teak, which
historically comes from India
and southeast Asia, and then
we have also Calophyllum
inophyllum puna.
This was not in the
archaeological record,
but this is sort of what
was historically used
for making masts as bars.
We used that, but also in
conjunction with local woods,
Acacia nilotica, a lot of --
and, just [inaudible]
sort of basically as well.
And, what we saw is that
basically this wood,
which is over 40 tons
of wood that we used
for the construction, sort
of reflected not only sort
of the different
material cultures,
but also represented the routes
that we were actually trying
to replicate in some ways.
We then had a team
of 40 archaeologists,
shipwrights from India
as well as carpenters
from a technical
college on Oman.
And, model makers as
well, rope workers,
because it was entirely
sewn, and started working.
What was very interesting was
actually that they sew boats
in India, and we had
expert rope workers
that were actually stitching
and training our Omanis on how
to actually stitch
a boat together.
But, we rather foolishly thought
that we knew a fair amount
about this vessel based on
the archaeological evidence.
This piece is what I showed you,
that technical detail, the keel.
What I had never
actually thought
about is how you actually
sew this together.
They had to do it five
different times to try and come
up with a reliable pattern.
I use this just as an example,
because every single aspect
or component of the
construction was similar.
We were sort of engaged
in all of these questions
that never really occurred to
us until we actually were forced
to try and reconstruct
it to a certain degree.
Had over 37,000 holes, because
it was actually stitched.
We did a rather extensive
documentation process
throughout, measured
every single stitch.
How long it took,
who did it, etcetera,
measured every single
piece on the vessel.
Did three D scans when we put
it in the water and afterwards,
measured individual frames.
You can also see this
is on the inside.
It took about a year
to build in general.
Incredible process to watch,
soft of, from beginning
to end rather than sort of
trying to look at the remains
and to puzzle out what
actually happened.
This is her just before
we put her in the water.
There were a few issues with
that, but she got in eventually,
and this is during sea trials.
We then spent five months
afterwards making the mast,
the spars, the sails, the
rigging, doing sea trials,
making sure that it
was everything okay.
And, then we sailed across
the Indian Ocean on 2010
over a six month period
on the basically --
a month to get from
Muscat to Cochin.
Spent a month in India doing
maintenance and repairs,
and then two weeks to Sri Lanka,
and then over across the Bay
of Bengal down through Malaysia,
and arriving in Singapore.
One of the interesting things
about the journey as well was
that in sort of studying the
ship, we, what you would call,
maritime archaeologists
are excessively focused
on construction largely, because
that's all we were actually
left with.
But, there are some
limited texts
that actually talk
about voyaging.
There's also navigational texts.
We were able to encounter,
what you would call,
the full spectrum of what
might one actually encounter.
We had -- the crew,
I forget, yes.
First of all, the
crew, which was --
and, the captain of course,
Captain Saleh al-Jabri,
was the command -- Omani naval
officer, 22 years' experience
from the sail training
ship, the Shabab Oman.
We had around 18 to
20 crew at the time.
It was ten Omanis
that were a part
of a 15 member permanent crew.
This is the permanent crew
here, as well as two Americans.
Robert Jackson is also
here, sitting over here,
and myself as well as an Italian
and two Indian rope worker,
carpenters in case
there were any issues.
And, there were issues of
course, as well as a rotating,
what you would call,
desk members.
A variety of members from those
countries that we were visiting.
We had two Singaporeans,
an Indian, two Sri Lankans,
a Malaysian, as well
as two camera men
for the National Geographic
documentary on the voyage.
The father of the ship, Aba
Supina [phonetic], Tom Vosmer,
and Luka, the site manager
for construction, and the goat
and the chicken who did not
make it to the other end,
guest members definitely.
Here we all are with
our headgear.
We would only wear this actually
when arriving for
video purposes.
Otherwise we wore
baseball hats and such.
But, encountered
everything from,
what you would call,
deadening calms.
Like this, this sort of
epitomizes to me the first month
of sailing across
the India Ocean.
Just sitting for days
often, very limited wind.
Our average speed was around
just over two miles an hour
across the India Ocean.
Gives you an idea of how
slow you can actually mean.
The flip side however
is on the Bay
of Bengal we encountered
perhaps too much wind
when we accidentally sailed
through the southern
edge of Cyclone Laila.
Encountered -- here
we are, 50-knot winds,
seas in the excess of
three to four meters,
taking on seven tons
of sea water a day.
A fair amount of -- but,
what was really interesting
was how resilient
and strong the ship was.
A lot of the sort of historical
records say how Marco Polo says
they're terrible ships, and that
he wouldn't ever ride in one,
but they're actually much
stronger and more resilient
than we'd actually anticipated.
We also cracked our mast,
broke our mast in the squall,
and fixed it, and had to
limp in and find a new mast
in Sri Lanka, which again
I hadn't really considered.
But, then now actually
experiencing it,
and going through all
of the Arabic literature
of the time period, I'm --
we're finding references
to broken masts everywhere,
and sort of reevaluating
and sort of trade routes
and the degrees to which
the difficult we've had
in finding masts.
Often, sort of timber
sources along these routes is
very important.
We also had to wonderful
opportunity to experiment
with Western Indian
Ocean navigation,
what we referred to it.
It wasn't ninth century.
The only texts we have on Indian
Ocean navigation are from 15th
and 16th centuries,
[foreign language spoken],
but we took both those texts
with us, and we did a variety
of celestial sort of star
altitude measurements while we
were actually traveling across.
Navigation was GPS,
full admission,
but we were experimenting with
it sort of a rather interesting
and unusual conclusions.
There was also, what you would
call, a whole other educational,
popular media, and diplomatic
dimensions to the project.
This was on one hand a gift
from one nation to another,
so diplomatic relations
were being strengthened
on visiting every country.
Elaborate banquets, some of the
best banquets I've ever been
to were on this voyage.
But, there was also a
pronounced educational element,
both within Oman, we had
over 20,000 students come
through our humble boat
yard looking at sort of how
to actually build a sewn
vessel, learning more
about their maritime
heritage in general,
but also engaging students
and doing academic workshops
as we were on the voyage.
This is my colleague Alessandro
Ghidoni, demonstrating how
to use a Hashiba [phonetic]
navigational instrument
to a group of Sri Lankan
school children as well,
and we were doing this India and
Malaysia and Singapore as well.
So, the whole goal
of it was sort
of educational at the same time.
Now, what does this have to
do with cultural tourism?
Yes, this was the
puzzle I was trying
to put this presentation
together to make it sort
of connect in some
way, shape, or form.
But, one of the very interesting
things I have to admit
on this voyage is
that in participating
in this entire project
of about two years,
I have to admit I was
originally, before participating
in this project, I was rather
skeptical of the benefits
of experimental archaeology
to a certain degree.
This project completely
converted me.
I felt in the two years that I
engaged in this I learned more
than my several years,
I don't want
to admit how many,
in graduate school.
And, what I found to be --
it was an incredibly
educational experience.
And, it also occurred to me
the ways in which a ship,
in particular an experimental,
archaeological reconstruction,
is the ideal platform for
cultural tourism tours
for high-end, sustainable
tourism that say, for example,
Dr. Thornton is talking about,
that combine not just cultural
tourism, but also engage them
in research, educational
research basically as well.
So, this is my suggestion as a
potential, what you would call,
innovative and unusual and
potentially fertile way of,
what you would call,
exploring the cultural tourism
opportunities and emphasizing
the maritime heritage of Oman.
All right, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
My apologies.
They cut it off, thank you
to every -- the project --
yes, thank you, my
acknowledgments.
This was a huge project that had
an incredible amount of people.
I would be here for another
20 minutes mentioning them all
if I had, but very thankful to,
first of all, the
Omani government.
His majesty the Sultan, for
actually having the vision
to initiate it, but also the
project was run by the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs under his
secretary general's office,
his excellency Sayyid
Badr Al-Busaidi,
as well as Dr. Sayyid's
office, the office --
I always mess it up, but
the adviser to his majesty,
the Sultan, for cultural
affairs.
As well as the Ministry of
Man Power for providing many
of the Omani carpenters as
well, and the Singapore Ministry
of Foreign Affairs, the
Singapore Tourism Board,
as well as all of the
wonderful photographers
and technical [inaudible]
that provided the images.
The only image in that entire
presentation is actually this
one of mine, is the only
photo that actually worth --
Robert takes -- an
excellent photographer,
a large amount of credit.
But, thank you to all of them
and the construction crew
and the sailing crew as well.
Thank you again, all right.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: Thank you
so much, Dr. Staples.
That was absolutely fascinating.
Ready for a ride on the replica.
I think we have about two,
three minutes for a couple
of questions, and then
we'll do a little wrap up.
So, does someone have a
question for our panelists?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Audience Member: All right,
if this was already covered
when I was out for a
minute, I apologize
and withdraw the question.
Did any of you place in context
for the audience the various
places that various people say
that Ahmad ibn Majid was
from, born and raised?
Some say Tulfa [assumed
spelling]
in Ruselkama [assumed spelling],
some say Suah [assumed
spelling], and others say,
well look at where
-- it's Sinbad.
That means probably
something closer to Karachi.
It would educate
all of us, I think,
if you were to generalize,
specifically clear that up.
>> Dr. Muhannad Salhi: I
will answer this question.
Ahmad ibn Majid was
born actually in Galfar,
and he is an Omani when it
was United Arab Emirates,
part of Oman.
>> Audience Member:
That's right.
>> Dr. Muhannad Salhi: So, we
don't have a doubt where he was,
or what they call it, where he
was born and the nationality.
And, we connect Ahmad ibn
Majid with Sinbad, yes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Dr. Eric Staples:
Sure, [inaudible].
>> Audience Member:
I felt like Joan.
I felt like going sailing
on your dhow, but I wanted
to ask what about
modern facilities?
What about sailing such
a long distance on a ship
that was structured
basically, what, 1000 years ago,
how do you as a modern
person are able to sail
for such a long distance
in a ship really not equipped
the way a modern ship is?
And, also I wanted to ask
about safety, in other words,
you know, Sinbad the sailor and
the -- has all these adventures,
and there's always the ship that
is hit by a wave or by a whale,
and he ends up on an island.
And, you know, until
another ship sails by,
and then he takes it, but
you were going to Singapore.
There are these huge
storms, and so on.
Was there some form of
security that you had?
Where there some plane
hovering above you?
Was there another
ship, you know,
motorized boat to help you?
So, I'm just trying to think
about a modern sailor
sailing on an old ship.
What is that experience like?
>> Dr. Eric Staples: I think --
I think anyone that
experiences this had
to be truly honest
with themselves.
You're not actually experiencing
what they experienced,
and I think that's impossible.
And, I don't think we
were even engaging in,
what's often called,
experiential learning,
sort of like these
Civil War reenactments.
We were trying to best
understand what we could
document about the
sailing performance.
We also, with the --
what you would call,
with the Western Indian
Ocean pre-modern navigation,
we were trying to
sort of put the pieces
of the puzzle together in
ways that haven't applied
to say Polynesian navigation.
They learned a fair amount
from Polynesian navigation
by actually applying it rather
than just reading about it.
But, the motto of the voyage
was 21st century safety,
ninth century everything else.
Now, again that wasn't
completely accurate.
We had Snickers, and a few
other modern amenities,
but the safety was
obviously a concern.
It was a concern throughout,
so we were doing --
and, I think it's a
testament to Captain Saleh
and his navy training.
He was doing constant drills.
We were doing constant fire
drills, man over board drills.
Robert, in addition to being
one of the crew members,
was also our medic as well
and was trained for that.
We had life rafts on
board basically as sort
of emergency life rafts
for all the vessels.
We were required to wear life
-- inflatable life jackets
and harnesses at night,
and I think it's a
testament we actually --
no one ever fell overboard
during the actual voyage.
Two people fell overboard
during the sea trials
in rather humorous events,
but during the actual voyage
no one actually fell overboard,
and that was a testament
to the training.
We did have an escort vessel for
the Malaysian portion largely,
because we were sailing
through the Straits of Malacca.
We had no engine, and
it's a very narrow passage
with an incredible amount
of modern shipping coming
through that cannot
basically turn.
So, and we -- very challenging,
we would go 50 miles forward
and 50 miles back
due to the currents
and having a escort vessel
there for that, but the rest
of it we were without an escort
vessel basically once we left
Omani waters.
So, but that being said I
felt much safer on the vessel
than you would probably think.
In some ways I, full disclosure,
I grew up on sail boats.
I spent about ten years of
my life living on sail boats.
What was immediately
apparent was not
so much the safety issues.
I trusted the vessel to
an incredible degree,
but was the -- how much more
labor intensive the entire
project was.
You know, to raise a
sail took eight people.
It -- you know, and to
raise both sails you needed,
you know, 16 people.
You needed full crew, and
-- but, also, you know,
experimenting with traditional
latrines I think was the term,
toiletries and traditional
cooking methods,
and all the rest of it
was also very interesting
and educational I would say.
I hope that's answered
your question, yes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Audience Member: So, the
question is for Dr. Chris.
You showed a slide where you
gave us the sort of impression
that most American tourists
don't go beyond the superficial,
Muttrah Souq and all that.
The impression I get,
and I could be wrong,
is that German tourists tend
to be a little more in depth
when it comes to Oman.
They tend to go to, you know,
places beyond Muttrah Souq.
Do you have an opinion
or theory as to why is it
that German tourists are
more -- I mean, are they --
is Oman marketed better
towards them compared
to what is being done
towards Americans,
or are they just
more adventurous?
>> Dr. Chris: Yeah, so this
is a fully qualitative answer,
because I have not
looked into the data,
but from my observations
the vast majority
of German tourists
are the cruise ship,
pour into the Muttrah
Souq, buy a dishdasha,
and get back on the boat.
The ones that you're
referring to is,
when you go into the interior
you'll be out in the middle
of nowhere, and you'll run
into a random group of hikers
who are inevitably German or
Polish, and they're living
out in, you know, somewhere
out in the mountains.
And, they're a little
more adventurous,
and I think there is a marketing
that through certain
travel companies.
So, for example, when we would
go to these medieval villages
and to these little eco
lodges, the only places
that they were really
getting tourists
from were Germany and Poland.
And, again they were getting
maybe five a month, right, very,
very, very, very small, and
this is not high-end tourism.
It's more like adventure
tourism.
These are people who like to
go hiking in the mountains.
They want to disappear,
so they plop their stuff
at the eco lodge, and they
take a tent and off they go,
and then the eco lodge doesn't
see them for three days.
But, it's a very, I
think, qualitatively,
it's a very small
minority of tourists,
and I could not guess
how that happened or why,
but it seems to be the case.
>> Dr. Joy McCorriston: Hi,
this is really for all of you,
but as someone who works in
Dhofar, I just want to --
I mean, my impression
of tourism in Oman is
that the vast majority
of tourists
in Oman are Emiratis coming down
to enjoy, and Saudis perhaps,
coming to enjoy the
Dhofar monsoon.
And, so in anything that is sort
of interpretive and thinking
about sustainability, I assume
that that group also would need
to be very much consulted and
in the picture of, sort of,
objectives in future
development,
at least for the southern part.
>> Dr. Chris: Yeah, obviously
I don't work in Dhofar.
I think you're absolutely
right, Joy.
That is a major a
tour group in Dhofar
that needs to be considered.
In the north, one thing that
I know Dr. Cable has worked
on a lot at Bat, is that
fact that the vast majority
of tourists that come to
Bat are actually Omanis.
And, that's a demographic that's
not often talked about even
by the Ministry of Tourism,
because they're Omanis.
They're not tourists.
But, they are actually
the largest group
that would come to Bat.
And, so Dr. Cable
worked for two years
with two local women
in particular.
So, we would often get women
groups, right, Charlotte?
It was the large groups of Omani
women who would come together
in a big van, and they'd
go to see the site,
and then they'd get back in the
van and go where ever they went.
And, Charlotte worked with
two local women to get a bunch
of signs and information
made in Arabic,
specifically targeting
both the local schools,
but also these Omani tourists.
So, I think to your point Joy,
it's not just about Americans
and Germans and French coming.
There's also a huge, huge market
for Omanis and other, you know,
Arab tourists to this
region, particularly
to Dhofar during
the summer months,
and that isn't often considered,
and I think that's a
really important point.
Thank you.
>> Dr. Joan Weeks: Well,
I'd like to thank everyone
for coming today,
and I especially want
to commend these panels.
These fantastic presentations
today,
so if we can give
another round of applause
to all our presenters.
[ Applause ]
And, on behalf of all my
colleagues in the African
and Middle Eastern Division
at the Library of Congress,
and the Sultan Qaboos
Cultural Center,
particularly Kathleen Ridolfo
and Harrison Gotherin
[assumed spellings]
who are the glue
behind the scenes
that made all this possible.
Give them a round
of applause, too.
[ Applause ]
We just look forward to having
these presentations available,
hopefully in a webcast format
eventually, and thank you all
so much for coming
and enlightening us
with these amazing
tourism opportunities,
cultural heritage
opportunities, in Oman.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at llc.gov.